continuous integration is a major step
in the divorce lifecycle it makes the
development testing and deployment of
applications easier and faster there are
a number of continuous integration tools
like bamboo Apache come Jenkins build
bot and Travis CI and among them Jenkins
is the most popular hi guys welcome to
this complete Jenkins tutorial by simply
learn my name is sandy and today we'll
be covering the most important
continuous integration tool that is
Jenkins first we will understand what is
DevOps and look at an introduction to
divorce then we will see how to install
Jenkins in Windows after that we will
learn what is Jenkins look at a tutorial
on Jenkins and understand how Jenkins
pipeline works finally we have
hand-picked some of the most important
Jenkins questions that you might face in
a divorce interview let's first look at
a small animated video to understand
what is DevOps meet Tim Tim Bell's robot
in his lab a climate controlled and
pollution free environment once he's
done he drops the robot off at his
project partner Mia's house Mia takes it
out to her backyard to ensure that the
robot meets the requirements but here is
where the problem arises the change in
the environment causes the robot to
malfunction Mia is now really annoyed
and she has a lot to correct and it
seems to her as though Tim didn't really
do much this wall between them leaves
the poor robot to bite the dust
well what if we broke this wall Tim and
me Anna work together in a common space
tim develops each block of functionality
of the robot which is then immediately
checked by Mia both are now working
simultaneously instead of waiting on the
other to finish their task as and when a
feature is ready for use they are put
together to build the final product the
developer common mindset and share ideas
to further speed up the process they use
several tools which can automate every
stage this means that the robot is now
ready sooner with less iterations and
manual work from an organization
perspective Tim would be the developer
while Mia the operations their union is
the core of the DevOps approach DevOps
has several stages and set of tools to
automate each of these stages
let's have a look at these Tim first
puts down a plan in terms of a software
this could mean deciding on the modules
and the algorithms to use once he has
the plan
he now codes the plan with tools such as
git tim has a repository for storing all
the codes and their different versions
this is called version control next this
code is fetched and made executable this
is the Bill stage tools such as cradle
and maven will sorts out now before
deployment the product is tested to
catch any bugs the most popular -
automating testing is selenium once the
products are tested
Mia must deploy the deployed product is
then continuously configure to the
desired state ansible puppet and docker
are some of the most common tools used
that automate these stages now every
product is continuously monitored in its
working environment Nagios is one such
tool that automates this space and the
feedback is fed back to the planning
stage and finally we have the code of
the DevOps lifecycle the integration
stage tools such as Jenkins is
responsible for sending the code for
build and test if the code passes the
tests it's further sent for deployment
this is called continuous integration
let's now have a look at an organization
that has adopted the DevOps approach
which of the below sequence of steps
would they follow to develop a software
linear answers in the comment section
keep an eye out for the right answer on
the
section or a YouTube community giant
such as Amazon Netflix Target Etsy and
Walmart have all adopted DevOps and seen
a considerable increase in delivery and
quality in 2014 and hour of downtime for
Netflix would cost two hundred thousand
dollars it became absolutely crucial
that Netflix prepared themselves for any
sort of failure and so they took to the
DevOps approach and implemented it in
the most unique way they develop the
tool called simian army this tool
created failures and automatically
deployed them in an environment that did
not affect the users the team would
trouble show these failures and this
give them enough experience to deal with
any degree of collapse with everything
being automated and happening
simultaneously organizations can now
deliver at a much faster pace so
considering the benefits of DevOps and
its divergence from the traditional
methods what DevOps be the future let us
know what you think in the comment
section below and with that we come to
an end of our video I hope you are
excited to learn more about DevOps and
Jenkins now we have Matthew apeksha
antonin who will take you through this
journey of learning Jenkins in detail
with that over to you Matthew
this is Matthew will simply learn and
today we're gonna go through and
introduce you to DevOps when it go
through a number of key elements today
the first two will be reviewing models
that you're already probably using for
delivering solutions into your company
and the most popular one is waterfall
followed by agile then we'll look at
DevOps and how DevOps differs from the
two models and how it also borrows and
leverages the best of those models we'll
go through each of the phases that are
used in typical DevOps delivery and then
the tools use within those phases to
really improve the efficiencies within
DevOps finally we'll summarize the
advantages that DevOps brings to you and
your teams so let's go through waterfall
so what
is a traditional delivery model that's
being used for many decades for
delivering solutions not just IT
solutions and digital solutions but
either way before that it has its
history it goes back to World War two
so waterfall is a model that is used to
capture requirements and they cascade
each key deliverable through a series of
different stage gates that is used for
building out the solution so let's take
you through each of those stage gates
the first that you may have done is
requirements analysis and this is where
you sit down with the actual client and
you understand specifically what they
actually do and what they're looking for
in the software that you're going to
build and then from that requirement
analysis you'll build out a project
planning so you have an understanding of
what the level of work is needed to be
able to be successful in delivering the
solution after that you've got your plan
then you start doing the development and
that means that the program is start
coding out their solution that build out
their applications that build out the
website and this can take weeks or even
months to actually do all the work when
you've done your coding and development
then you send it to another group that
does testing and they'll do full
regression testing of your application
against the systems and databases that
integrate with your application you'll
test it against the actual code you'll
do manual testing you do UI testing and
then after you've delivered the solution
you go into maintenance mode which is
just kind of making sure that the
application keeps working there's any
security risks that you address those
security risks but the problem you have
though is that there are some challenges
however that you have with the waterfall
model the cascading deliveries and those
complete and separated stage gates means
that it's very difficult for any new
requirements from the client to be
integrated into the project so if a
client comes back and it's the project
has been running for six months and
they've gone hey we need to change
something that means that we have to
almost restart the whole project it's
very expensive
and it's very time-consuming also if you
spend weeks and months away from your
and you deliver a solution that they are
only just going to see after you spend a
lot of time working on it
they could be pointing out things that
are in the actual final application that
they don't want or are not implemented
correctly or lead to just general
unhappiness the chance you then have is
if you want to add bank in the clients
feed bank to restart the whole waterful
cycle again so the client will come back
to you with a list of changes and then
you go back and you have to start your
programming and you have to then start
your testing process again and just
you're really adding in lots of
additional time into the project so
using the waterfall model companies have
soon come to realize that you know the
clients just aren't able to get their
feedback in quickly effectively it's
very expensive to make changes once the
team's have started working and the
requirement in today's digital world is
that solutions simply must be delivered
faster and this has led for a specific
change in agile and we start
implementing the agile model so the
agile model allows programmers to create
prototypes and get those prototypes to
the client with the requirements faster
and the client is able to then send the
requirements back to the programmer with
feedback this allows us to create what
we call a feedback loop we're able to
get information to the client and the
client can get back to the development
team much faster typically when we were
actually going through this process
we're looking at the engagement cycle
being about two weeks and so it's much
faster than the traditional waterfall
approach and so we can look at each
feedback loop as comprising of four key
elements we have the planning where we
actually sit down with the client and
understand what they're looking for we
then have coding and testing that is
building out the code and the solution
that is needed for the client and then
we review with the clients the changes
that have happened but we do all this in
a much tighter cycle that we call a
sprint and then typically a sprint will
last for about two weeks
some companies run sprints every week
some run every four weeks it's up to you
as a team to decide how long you want
achieve run as
but typically it's two weeks and so
every two weeks the client is able to
provide feedback into that loop and so
you were able to move quickly through
iterations and so if we get to the end
of sprint 2 and the client says hey you
know what we need to make a change you
can make those changes quickly and
effectively for Sprint 3 what we have
here is a breakdown of the ceremonies
and the approach that you bring to agile
so typically what will happen is that a
product leader will build out a backlog
of products and what we call a product
backlog and still be just a whole bunch
of different features and they may be
small features or bug fixes all the way
up to large features that may actually
spent over multiple sprints but when you
go through the sprint planning you want
to actually break out the work that
you're doing so the team has a mixture
of small medium and large solutions that
they can actually implement successfully
into this 4 into plan and then once you
achieve start running your sprint again
it's a two-week activity you meet every
single day the two with the agile sprint
team to ensure that everybody is staying
on track and if there's any blockers for
those blockers are being addressed
effectively and immediately the goal at
the end of the two weeks is to have a
deliverable product that you can put in
front of the customer and the customer
can then do a review the key advantages
you have of running a sprint with agile
is that the client requirements are
better understood because the client is
really integrated into the scrum team
they're there all the time and the
product is delivered much faster than
with a traditional waterfall model
you're delivering features at the end of
each sprint versus waiting weeks months
or in some cases years for a waterfall
project to be completed however there
are also some distinct disadvantages the
product itself really doesn't get tested
in a production round it's only being
tested on the developer computers and
it's really hard when you're actually
running agile for the Sprint team to
actually build out a solution easily and
effectively on their computers to mimic
the production environment
and the developers and the operations
team are running in separate silos so
you have your development team running
their sprint and actually working to
build out the features but then when
they're done at the end of their sprint
and they want to do a release they kind
of fling it over the wall at the
operations team and then it's the
operations team job to actually install
the software and make sure that the
environment is running in a stable
fashion that is really difficult to do
when you have the two teams really not
working together so here we have is a
breakdown of that process with the
developers submitting their work to the
operations team for deployment and then
the operations team may submit their
work to the production servers but what
if there is an error what if there was a
setup configuration error with the
developers test environment that doesn't
match the production environment there
may be a dependency that isn't there
there may be a link to an API that
doesn't exist in production and so you
have these charges that the operations
team are constantly faced with and their
challenge is that they don't know how
the code works
so this is where DevOps really comes in
and let's dig into how DevOps which is
developers and operators working
together is the key for successful
continuous delivery so DevOps is as an
evolution of the agile model the agile
model really is great for gathering
requirements and for developing and
testing out your solutions and what we
want to be able to do is kind of address
that challenge and that gap between the
ops team and the dev team and so with
DevOps what we're doing is bringing
together the operations team and the
development team into a single team and
they are able to then work more
seamlessly together because they are
integrated to be able to build out
solutions that are being tested in a
production like environment so that when
we actually deploy we know that the code
itself will work the operations team is
then able to focus on what they're
really good at which is analyzing the
production environment and being able to
provide feedback to the developers on
what is being successful so we're able
to make adjust
in our code that is based on data so
let's step through the different phases
of a DevOps team so typically you'll see
that the DevOps team will actually have
eight phases now this is somewhat
similar to agile and what I would like
to point out at time is that again agile
and DevOps are very closely related but
agile devops are closely related
delivery models that you can use with
DevOps it's really just extending that
model with the key phases that we have
here so let's step through each of these
key phases so the first phase is
planning and this is where we actually
sit down with a business team and we go
through and understand what their goals
are the second stage is as you can
imagine and this is where it's all very
similar to agile is that the code is
actually start coding but they typically
they'll start using tools such as git
which is a distributed version control
software it makes it easier for
developers to all be working on the same
code base rather than bits of the code
that is rather than them working on bits
of the code that they are responsible
for so the goal with using tools such as
git is that each developer always has
the current and latest version of the
code you then use tools such as mavin
and Gradle as a way to consistently
build out your environment and then we
also use tools to actually automate our
testing now what's interesting is when
we use tools like selenium and J unit is
that we're moving into a world where our
testing is scripted the same as our
build environment and the same as using
our get around we can such scripting out
these environments and so we actually
have scripted production environments
that we're moving towards Jenkins is the
integration phase that we use for our
tools and another point here is that the
tools that we're listing here these are
all open source tools these are tools
that any team can start using we want to
have tools that control and manage the
deployment of code into the production
environments and then finally tour such
as ansible and chef will actually
operate and manage those production
environments so that when code comes to
them that that code is compliant with
the
environment so that when the code is
then deployed to the many different
production servers that the expected
results of those servers which is you
want them to continue running is
received and then finally you monitor
the entire environment so you can just
zero in on spikes and issues that are
relevant to either the code or changing
consumer habits on the site so let's
step through some of those tools that we
have in the DevOps environments so here
we have is a breakdown of the DevOps
tools that we have and again one of the
things I want to point out is that these
tools are open source tools there are
also many other tools this is just
really a selection of some of the more
popular tools that are being used but
it's quite likely that you're already
using some of these tools today you may
already be using Jenkins you may already
be using git but some of the other tools
really help you create a fully
scriptable environment so that you can
actually start scripting out your entire
DevOps toolset this really helps when it
comes to speeding up your delivery
because the more you can actually script
out of the work that you're doing the
more effective you can be at running
automation against those scripts and the
more effective you can be at having a
consistent experience so let's step
through this DevOps process so we go
through and we have our continuous
delivery which is our plan code build
and test environment so what happens if
you want to make it release well the
first thing you want to do is send out
your files to the building round and you
want to be able to test the code that
you've been created because we're
scripting everything in our code from
the actual unit testing being done to
the all the way through to the
production environment because we're
testing or that we can very quickly
identify whether or not there are any
defects within the code if there are
defects we can send that code right back
to the developer with a message saying
what the defect is and the developer can
then fix that with information that is
real on the either the code or the
production environment if however your
passes the the scripting tests they can
then be deployed and once it's out to
deployment you can then start monitoring
that environment what this provides you
is the opportunity to speed up your
delivery so you go from the waterfall
model which is weeks months or even
years between releases to agile which is
two weeks or four weeks depending on
your sprint cadence to where you are
today with DevOps where you can actually
be doing multiple releases every single
day so there are some significant
advantages and there are companies out
there that are really zeroing in on
those advantages if we take any one of
these companies such as Google Google
any given date will actually process
fifty two hundred new releases on their
website through their DevOps teams in
fact they have some great videos on
YouTube that you can find out on how
their develop teams work Netflix is also
a similar environment now what's
interesting with Netflix is that Netflix
have really fully embraced DevOps within
their development team and so they have
a DevOps team and Netflix is a
completely digital company so they have
software on phones on smart TVs on
computers and on websites interestingly
though the DevOps team for Netflix is
only 70 people and when you consider
that a third of all internet traffic on
any given day is from Netflix it's
really a reflection on how effective
DevOps can be when you can actually
manage that entire business with just 70
people so there are some key advantages
that DevOps has it's the actual time to
create and deliver software is
dramatically reduced particularly
compared to waterfall complexity of
maintenance is also reduced because
you're automating and scripting out your
entire environment you're improving the
communication between all your teams so
teams don't feel like they're in
separate silos but that are actually
working cohesively together and that
there is continuous integration and
continuous delivery so that your
consumer your customer
is constantly being delighted today we
see how to install a very popular
continuous integration tool called
Jenkins on windows first we see how to
install Java development kit jdk is one
of the prerequisites you need in order
to run Jenkins then we'll set up the jdk
path in the environment with you after
that we'll see how to download and
install Jenkins on Windows once that's
complete
we'll run Jenkins on localhost:8080
which is the default port for running
Jenkins then we have a glance at the
Jenkins server interface and look at
some of features present on Jenkins
finally we learn how to build and run a
job in Jenkins to download and install
JDK simply type install JDK on Google
and click on the first link which is
Java s8 development to get it as you can
see we get a list of downloads for JDK
since I'm on windows 64-bit system I
have already installed JDK version for
Windows 64 before you install JDK you
also need to accept the license
agreement let me show you where my jdk
has been installed first I go to my C
Drive Program Files under the Java
folder you find two more folders that's
JDK and JRE now let's setup the path in
the environment variable go to system
properties under the Advanced tab select
environment variables under system
variables there are two more variables
called Java home and JRE who Java home
contains the path for JDK I'll show you
where it is go to JDK folder copy the
path and paste it in the value section
JRE home contains the path for GRE
similarly go to the GRE folder copy the
path and paste it in the corresponding
value one more thing you need to do is
setup the bin folder location for JDK in
path variables let's see where the bin
folder location is
here it is after setting up the location
click OK to finish the setup now shall
we check if Java has been successfully
installed for that go to the command
prompt and type Java - version you can
see our Java is successfully installed
and it's up and running
the version we've installed is shown
here now let's download Jenkins on
windows simply type download Jenkins and
Google and click on the first link here
we can see my Jenkins provides two types
of releases long term support release
and weekly release as I'm interested in
a more stable release so I will go for
LTS now when I scroll down I'll get an
option for Windows once I select that a
stable installer starts to download you
can see it says thank you for
downloading windows stable installer so
now our Jenkins has start downloading
this might take a few seconds
to learn maybe you can catch up if you
left behind
okay so the download is complete now
let's go ahead and unzip downloaded
Jenkins fire
after the unzipping has been done we
start the installation click on this
folder click run next this is the
default path where Jenkins will be
installed we don't need to change it so
we can just go at the next install after
this the Jenkins installation is
successfully completed select finish yes
that's all
now that installation is complete let's
go and explore Jenkins go to your web
browser and search localhost colon 8080
0 you can see that it says welcome to
Jenkins so I have already created the
username and password for Jenkins I'll
enter my credentials and that's all this
is how the Jenkins homepage and
interface looks like and that's all
signing in yes so that's the dashboard
and this is how the Jenkins homepage and
interface looks like so if you're
installing Jenkins for the very first
time it will ask you to install some
recommended plugins I have already
installed mine so I don't need to
install them once again now there are a
lot of things you can do in Jenkins let
me run you through a few of them there's
some jobs that have already created and
run this is new item it allows you to
create a new project so you can create a
freestyle project for mavin project a
builds pipeline etc then going back to
the dashboard there is built history so
this section shows you the status of
your build here you can see what's the
builds name the time since the build is
running and what's the status of your
build
there is another very important section
called manage Jenkins
here you can configure your system you
can configure global security
credentials then there's some global
tool configuration you can also download
and manage your plugins here you can see
there four tabs where you have some
updates you have some available plugins
you have the plugins that you've already
installed and then there is advanced
plug-in as well now let me show you how
to create and run a job in Jenkins so
coming back to the dashboard let me
select new item we can name our job here
let me name the job as Jenkins demo I
will create a freestyle project so
select that and click OK
this might take a few seconds so when we
have created that here we have a number
of options that we can go ahead with you
have a source code management building
triggers building environment and then
of course some post build actions
so that's about creating and running a
job on Jenkins let's give some
description to our job so we have
creates the job
we give description something like this
is my first Chen Keens job so we will
not use any source code management tool
in the build section as you can see
there is an option to execute windows
batch command
click on that and here you can give you
command let's use the echo command I
would write something like hello this is
my first Jenkins demo and then I'll also
give the date and time parameters so
that I can track on what date and time
this job was built
that's it so click apply and then save
okay so this job is created now let's
build it go to bills now once you click
it you can see a built history has been
created click on that
in the console output you can see the
output of your very first Jenkins job
it says hello this is my first Jenkins
demo what you gave in the command box
you can see that and you can also see
the day date and time when this job was
created so we've successfully created
our first Jenkins job hello this is
Matthew from simply learn and today
we're going a deep dive into what
Jenkins is and how it improves your
DevOps continuous integration
environments so this is what we're going
to be covering in this session when they
cover what life is like before using
Jenkins and the issues that Jenkins
specifically addresses then we'll get
into what Jenkins is about and how it
applies to continuous integration and
the other continuous integration tools
that you need in your DevOps team then
specifically we will deep dive into
features of Jenkins and the Jenkins
architecture and we'll give you a case
study of a company that's using Jenkins
today to actually transform how their IT
organization is operating so let's talk
a little bit about life before Jenkins
let's see this scenario I think it's
something that maybe all of you can
relate to as developers we all write
code and we all submit that code into a
code repository and we all keep working
away writing our unit tests and
hopefully we're running our unit tests
but the problem is that the actual
commits that actually gets sent to the
code repository aren't consistent you as
a developer may be based in India you
may have another developer that's based
in the Philippines and you may have
another team leaders based in the UK and
another development team that's based in
North America so you're all working at
different times and you have different
amounts of code going into the code
repository there's issues with the
integration and you're kind of running
into a situation that we'd like to call
development hell where things just
aren't working out and there's just lots
of delays being added into the project
and the bugs just keep mounting up the
bottom line is the project is delayed
and in the past what we would have to do
is we'd have to wait until the entire
software code was built and tested
before we could even begin checking for
errors and this just really kind of
increased the amount of problems that
you'd have in your project the actual
process of delivering software was slow
there was no way that you could actually
iterate on your software and you just
ended up with just a big headache with
teams pointing fingers at each other and
blaming each other so let's jump into
Jenkins and see what Jenkins is and how
it can address these problems so Jenkins
is a product that comes out of the
concept of continuous integration that
you may have heard of as power
developers where you'd have two
developers sitting next to each other
coding against the same piece of
information what they were able to do is
to continuously develop their code and
test their code and move on to new
sections of code Jenkins is a product
that allows you to expand on that
capacity to your entire team so you're
able to submit your codes consistently
into a source code environment so there
are two ways in which you can do
continuous delivery one is through
ninety builds and one is through
continuous so the approach that you can
look at continuous delivery is modifying
the legacy approach to building out
solutions so what we used to do is we
would wait for nightly builds and the
way that our nightly builds would work
and operate is that as code developers
we would all want and have a cut off
time at the end of the day and that was
consistent around the world that we
would put our codes into a single
repository and at night all of that code
would be run and operated and tested to
see if there were any changes and a new
build would be created that would be
referred to as the nightly build with
continuous integration we're able to go
one step further we're able to not only
commit our changes into our source code
but we can actually do this continuously
there's no need to race and have a team
get all that code in an arbitrary time
you can't you do a continuous release
because what you're doing is you're
putting your tests and your verification
services into the build environment so
you're always running cycles to test
against your code this is the power that
Jenkins provides you can't
integration so this dig deeper into
continuous integration so the concept of
continuous integration is that as a
developer you're able to call from a
repository the code that you're working
on and then you'll be able to then at
any time submit the code that you're
working on into a continuous integration
server and the goal of that continuous
integration server is that it actually
goes ahead and validates and passes any
tests that a tester may have created now
if on the continuous integration server
a test isn't passed then that code gets
sent back to the developer and the
developer can then make their changes it
allows the developer to actually do a
couple of things it allows the developer
not to break the build and we all don't
want to break the builds that are being
created but it also allows the developer
not to actually have to run all of the
tests locally on their computer write
tests particularly if you have a large
number of tests can take up a lot of
time so you can push that service up to
another environment like a continuous
integration server it really improves
the productivity of your developer
what's also good is that if there are
any code errors that are come up that
may be beyond just the standard CI test
so maybe there's a code with the way
that you write your code isn't
consistent those errors can then be
passed on easily from the tester back to
the developer to the goal from doing all
this testing is that you're able to
release and deploy and your customer is
able to get new code faster and when
they get that code it simply just works
let's talk a little bit about some of
the tools that you may have in your
continuous integration environment so
the cool thing with working with
continuous integration tools is that
they are all open source at least the
ones that we have listed here or open
source there are some that are private
but typically you'll get started with
open source tools and it gives you the
opportunity to understand how you can
accelerate your environment quickly so
bamboo is a continuous integration tool
that specifically runs multiple builds
in parallel for faster completion so if
you have multiple versions of your
software that runs on multiple platforms
this is a tool that really allows you to
get that up and running super fast so
that your teams can actually test how
those different builds would work for
different environments and this has
integration with ant and mavin and other
similar tools so one of the tools you're
going to need is a tool that allows you
to automate the software build test and
release process and Bill bot is that
open source product for you again it's
an open source tool so there's no
license associated with this so you can
actually go in and you can actually get
the environment up and running and you
can then test for and build your
environments and create your releases
very quickly so built BOTS also written
in Python and it does support pal
execution jobs across multiple platforms
if you're working specifically on Java
projects that need to be built and test
then Apache Gump is the tool for you it
makes all of those projects really easy
it makes all the Java projects easier
for you to be able to test with API
level and functionality level testing so
one of the popular places to actually
store code and create our version of
your code is github and it's a service
that's available on the web just
recently acquired by Microsoft if you
are storing your projects in github then
you'll be able to use Travis continuous
integration or Travis CI and it's a tool
designed specifically for hosted github
projects and so finally we're covering
Jenkins and Jenkins is a central tool
for automation for all of your projects
now when you're working with Jenkins
sometimes you have
there's documentation that refers to a
product called Hudson Hudson is actually
the original version of the product that
finally became Jenkins and it was
acquired by Oracle and when that
acquisition happened the team behind
Hudson was a little concerned about the
direction that Oracle may potentially go
with Hudson and so they created a hard
Fork of Hudson that they renamed Jenkins
and Jenkins has now become that
open-source product it is one of the
most popular and continuously
contributed projects that's available as
open source so you're always getting new
features being added to it it's a tool
that really becomes the Center for your
CI environment so this jump into some of
those really great features are
available in Jenkins so Jenkins itself
is really comprised of five key areas
around easy installation easy
configuration plugins extensibility and
distribution so as I mentioned for the
easy installation Jenkins is a
self-contained Java program and that
allows it to run on most popular
operating systems including Windows Mac
OS and UNIX you even run it on Linux
it really isn't too bad to setup it used
to be much harder than it is today the
setup process has really improved the
web interface makes it really easy for
you to check for any errors in addition
you have great built-in help one of the
things that makes tools like Jenkins
really powerful for developers and
continuous integration teams and your
DevOps teams as a whole when you have
plug-ins that you can then add in to
extend the base functionality of the
product Jenkins has hundreds of proteins
and you can go and visit the update
center and see which other plugins
that'd be good for your DevOps
environment certainly check it out
there's just lots of stuff out there in
addition to the plug-in architecture
Jenkins is also extremely extensible the
opportunity for you to be able to
configure Jenkins to fit in your
environment
it's almost endless no it's really
important to remember that you are
extending Jenkins not creating a custom
version of Jenkins and that's a great
differentiation because the core
foundation remains as the core Jenkins
product the extensibility can then be
continued with newer releases of Jenkins
so you're always having the latest
version of Jenkins and your extensions
mature with those a core foundation the
distribution and the nature of Jenkins
makes it really easy for you to be able
to have it available across your entire
network really will become the center of
your CI environment it's certainly one
of the easier tools and more effective
tools for DevOps so this jump into the
standard Jenkins pipeline so when you're
doing development you start off and
you're coding away on your computer the
first thing you have to do when you're
working in the Jenkins pipeline is to
actually commit your code now as a
developer this is something that you're
already doing or least you should be
doing you're committing your code to a
git server or to an SVN server or a
similar type of service so in this
instance you'll be using Jenkins as the
place for you to commit your code
Jenkins will then create a build of your
code and part of that build process is
actually going through and running
through tests and again as a developer
you're already comfortable with running
unit tests and writing those tests to
validate your code but there may be
additional tests that Jenkins is running
so for instance as a team you may have a
standard set of tests for how you
actually write out your code so that
each team member can understand the code
that's been written and those tests can
also be included in the testing process
within the Jenkins environment assuming
everything passed so yet the tests you
can then get everything placed in a
stage and release ready environment
within Jenkins and finally getting ready
to deploy or deliver your code to a
production environment Jenkins is going
to be the tool that helps you with your
server environment to be able to deploy
your code to the production environment
and the result is that you're able to
move from a developer to production code
really quickly this whole process can be
automated rather than having to wait for
people to actually test your
or going through a nightly build you're
looking at being able to commit your
code and go through this testing process
and release process continuously as an
example companies Etsy will release up
to 50 different versions of their
website every single day so let's talk
about the architecture within Jenkins
that allows you to be so effective at
applying a continuous delivery DevOps
environment so the server architecture
really is broken up into two sections on
the left hand side of section you have
the code the developers are doing and
submitting that code to a source code
repository and then from then jenkins is
your continuous integration server and
it will then pull any code that's been
sent to the source code repository and
will run tests against it they'll use a
build service such as mam in to actually
then build the code and every single
stage that we have that Jenkins manages
there are constant tests so for instance
ever build fails that it feedback is
sent right back to the developers so
that they can then change their code so
that the build environment can run
effectively the final stage is to
actually execute specific test scripts
and these test scripts can be written in
selenium so it's probably good to
mention here that both mavin and
selenium are plugins that run in the
Jenkins environment so before we were
talking about how Jenkins can be
extended with plugins mavin in selenium
are just two very popular examples of
how you can extend the Jenkins
environment the goal to go through this
whole process again it's an automated
process is to get your code from the
developer to the production server as
quickly as possible have it fully tested
and have no errors so it's probably
important at this point to mention one
piece of information around the Jenkins
environment that if you have different
code builds that need to be managed and
distributed this will require that you
need to have multiple builds being
managed
Jenkins itself doesn't allow for
multiple files and builds to be executed
on a single server you need to have a
multiple server environment with running
different versions of
jenkins for that to be able to happen so
this talk a little bit about the
master/slave architecture within jenkins
so what we have here is overview of the
master/slave architecture within jenkins
on the left hand side is the remote
source code repository and that remote
source code repository could be github
or it could be team foundation services
or the new agile dev ops code repository
or it could be your own get repository
the Jenkins server acts as the master
environments on the left hand side and
that master environment can then push
out to multiple other Jenkins slave
environments to distribute the workload
so allows you to run multiple builds and
tests and production environments
simultaneously across your entire
architecture so Jenkins slaves can be
running the different build versions of
the code for different operating systems
and that server master is controlling
how each of those builds operate so
let's step into a quick story of a
company that has used Jenkins very
successfully so here's a use case
scenario I'm over the last 10 or 15
years there has been a significant shift
within the automotive industry where
manufacturers have shifted from creating
complex Hardware to actually creating
software we've seen that with companies
such as Tesla where they are creating
software to manage their cars we see the
same thing with companies such as
General Motors with their OnStar program
and Ford just recently have rebranded
themselves as a technology company
rather than just a automotive company
what this means though is that the
software within these cars is becoming
more complex and requires more testing
to allow more capabilities enhancements
to be added to the core software so
Bosch is a company that specifically ran
into this problem and their challenge
was that they wanted to be able to
streamline the increasingly complex
automotive software by adopting
continuous integration and continuous
delivery best practices with the goal of
being able to delight and exceed the
customer expectations of the end user so
Bosch has actually used cloudBees which
is the enterprise Jenkins environment so
to be able to reduce them number of
manual steps such as building deploying
and testing Bosch has introduced the use
of cloud ease from Jenkins and this is
part of the enterprise Jenkins platform
has significantly helped improve the
efficiencies throughout the whole
software development cycle from
automation stability and transparency
because Jenkins becomes a self auditing
environment now the results have been
tangible previously it took three days
before a build process could be done and
now it's taken that same three day
process and reduced it to less than
three hours
that is significant large-scale
deployments are now kept on track and
have experts support and there is clear
visibility and transparency across the
whole operations through using the
Jenkins tools hello and welcome to
continuous integration tutorial using
Jenkins
my name is Chad Annan and I am with the
simply learned team today let's get
started with Jenkins Jenkins in my
opinion is one of the most popular
continuous integration servers of recent
times what began as a hobby project by a
developer working for Sun Microsystems
were back in early or mid 2000s has
gradually and eventually evolved into
very very powerful and robust automation
servers it has a wider option since it
is released under MIT license and is
almost free to use Jenkins has a vast
developer community that supports it by
writing all kinds of plugins plugins is
the heart and soul of Jenkins because
using plugins one can connect Jenkins to
anything and everything under the Sun
with that introduction let's get into
what all will be covered as a part of
this tutorial
I will get into some of the
prerequisites required for installing
Jenkins post with
I will go ahead and install Jenkins on a
Windows box there are a few first M
configuration that needs to be done and
I will be covering those as well so once
I have Jenkins installed and configured
properly I will get into the user
administrative part create few users and
I will use some plugins for setting up
various kinds of access permissions for
this users I will also put in some
freestyle jobs freestyle job is nothing
but a very very simple job and I will
also show you the powerfulness of
Jenkins by scheduling this particular
job to run based upon time schedule I
will also connect Jenkins with github
github is our source code source code
repository where I've got some
repositories put up there
so using Jenkins I will connect to
github pull up a repository that is
existing on github onto the Jenkins box
and run few commands to build this
particular repository that is pulled
from github sending out emails is a very
very important configurations of Jenkins
or any other continuous integration
server for that matter whenever there is
any notifications that has to be sent
out as a part of either build going bad
or by being good or building propagate
to some environment and all these
scenarios you would need the countries
integration servers to be sending out
notifications so I will get into a
little bit details of how to configure
Jenkins for sending out emails I will
also get into a scenario where I would
have a web application a maven based
Java web application which will be
pulled from a github repository and I
will deploy it onto a tomcat server the
tomcat server will be locally running on
my system eventually I will get into one
other very very important topic which is
the master slave configuration it's a
very very important and pretty
interesting topic where distributed
builds is achieved using a master slave
configuration so I will bring up a slave
I will connect the slave with the master
and I will also put in a job and kind of
delegate that particular job to the
slave configuration finally I will let
you know how to use some plugins to
backup your Jenkins
so Jenkins has got a lot of useful
information set up on it in terms of the
build environments in terms of workspace
all this can be very very easily backed
up using a plugin so this is what I'm
going to be covering as a part of this
tutorial
Jenkins is a web application that is
written in Java
and there are various ways in which you
can use and install Jenkins I have
listed popular three mechanisms in which
Dinkins is usually installed on in any
system the topmost one is as a Windows
or a Linux based services so if at all
you have Windows like the way I have and
I'm going to use this mechanism for this
demo so I would download a MSI installer
that is specific to Jenkins and install
this service so whenever you stirred as
a service
it goes out and nicely installs all that
is required for my Jenkins and I have a
service that can be started or stopped
based upon my need any flavor of Linux
is one one other way of running Jenkins
is downloading this generic war file and
as long as you have JDK installed you
can launch this war file by the command
opening up a command prompt or shell
prompt differ to later on Linux box
specifying Java
- jar and the name of this war file
typically brings up your web application
and you know you can continue with your
installation the only thing being if at
all you want to stop using Jenkins you
just go ahead and close this prompt even
into a control C and then bring down
this prompt and engine can serve what
would be down other older versions of
Jenkins were run popularly using this
way in which you already have a Java
based web server running up and running
so you kind of drop in this war file
into the root folder or the httpd root
folder of your web server so Jenkins
would explode and kind of bring up your
application all user credentials or user
administration is all taken care of by
the Apache or the Tomcat server or the
web server on which Jenkins is running
this was a very older way of running but
still some people use it because if they
don't want to maintain two servers if
they already have a Java web server
which it's being nicely maintained and
backed up Jenkins can't run a test to it
alright so either ways it doesn't matter
however you going to bring up your
Jenkins instance the way we gonna
operate Jenkins is all going to be very
very same or similar on but the subtle
changes in terms of user administration
if at all you're launching it through
any other web server which will take
care of the user administration
otherwise all the commands or all the
configuration or the way in which I'm
going to run this demo it is going to be
same across any of these installations
all right so the prerequisites for
running Jenkins as I mentioned earlier
Jenkins is nothing but a simple web
application there is a run in Java so
all that it needs is Java preferably jdk
1.7 or 1.8 2gb ram is the
amended ram for running jenkins and also
like any other open-source tool sets
when you install jdk ensure that you sit
in the environment variable Java home to
point to the right directory this is
something very specific to JDK but for
any other open-source tools that I've
installed there is always a preferred
environment variable that he got to sit
in which is specific to that particular
tool that you're gonna use this is a
generic thing that is there for you know
for any other open-source projects
because the weight open source projects
discover themselves he's using this
environment variables so as a general
practice or a good practice always set
these environment variables accordingly
so I already have jdk 1.8 installed on
my system but in case you do not what I
would recommend is just navigate on your
browser to the Oracle home page and just
type in our search for install jdk 1.8
mm page you'll have to accept the
License Agreement and there's a bunch of
installers that is okay that you can
pick up based upon the operating system
on which you're running so I have this
Windows 64 installer that is already
installed and running on my system so I
was not going to do the details of
downloading this or installing it let me
show you once I install this what I've
done with regard to my path so if you
get in those environment variables
all right so I have just sit in a Java
home variable if you see this sequel and
program friends Java JDK 1.8 this is
where my my Java is located c program
files c program files java okay so this
is the home directory of my JDK so that
is what I've been I've set it up here in
my environment variable
so if you see here this is my java home
alright
one other thing to do is ensure that in
case you want to run Java or Java Sea
from a command from ensure that you also
add that path into this path variable so
if you see this somewhere I will see yes
there you go
C colon program files Java JDK 1.8 pin
so with these two I'll ensure that my
Java installation is nice and you know
good enough so you check that to double
check that or to verify that let me just
open up a simple command prompt
if I type in Java - version alright and
Java C - version so the compiler is on
the path Java is on the path and if at
all I do this
even the environment variable specific
to my Java is installed correctly so I
am good to go ahead with my Jenkins
installation now that I have my
prerequisites all set for installing
Jenkins let me just go ahead and
download Jenkins so let me open up a
browser and say download Jenkins
all right LTS is nothing but the
long-term support these are all stable
versions weeklies I would not recommend
that you try these unless until you have
a real need for that long-term support
is good enough and as I mentioned there
are so many flavors of Jenkins that is
available for download you also have a
docker container wherein you know you
can launch in kins as a containers but
I'm not getting into details of that in
this tutorial alright so what I want is
yes this is the war file with a generic
war file that I was talking to you
earlier and this is the Windows MSI
installer so go ahead and in download
this MSI installer I already have that
downloaded so let me just open that up
alright so this is my downloaded Jenkins
instance I rather installer this is a
pretty maybe a few months old but this
is good enough for me before you start
Jenkins installation just be aware of
one fact that there is a variable called
Jenkins home this is fair Jenkins boot
store all this configuration data are
jobs for that workspace and all that
specific to Jenkins so by default if at
all you don't set this to any particular
directory if at all you install an MSI
installer all your installation gets
into C colon program files 86 and
Jenkins folder if at all you run a war
file depending upon the user ID with
which you're running a war file the
Jenkins folder there's a dot Jenkins
folder that gets created inside the user
home directory so in case you have any
need wherein you want to backup your
Jenkins or anyone Jenkins installation
so get into some specific directories go
ahead and set this Jenkins home variable
accordingly before you even begin your
installation for now I don't need to do
any of this thing so I've already
downloaded the Installer let me just go
ahead with the default installation
alright so this is my Jenkins MSI
installer I would just I don't want to
make any changes into the Jenkins
configuration C colon program files is
good for me yeah this is where all my
destination folder and all the
configuration specific to it goes I'm
happy with us I don't want to change
this I would just say go ahead and click
installation
okay so what typically happens once the
Jenkins installation gets through is
it'll start installing itself and there
is some small checks that needs to be
done so and by default Jenkins launches
on the port 8080 so let me just open up
localhost 8080 there's a small checking
that will be done as a part of the
installation process wherein I need to
type in the hash key alright so there's
a very very simple hash key that gets
stole out here so I'll have to just copy
this path
if at all you're running as a war file
you would see that in your logs alright
so this is a simple hash key that gets
created every time when you know
Jenkinson station so as a part of the
installation it just asks you to do this
so if that is not correct
it will crib about it but this looks
good so it's going ahead
all right one important part during the
installation so you would need to
install some recommended plugins what
happens is the plugins are all related
to each other so it's like the typical
rpm kind of a problem where you try to
install some plug-in and it's got a
dependency which is not installed and
you get into all those issues in order
to get rid of that what jenkins
recommends there's a bunch of plugins
that is already recommended so just go
ahead and blindly
click that install recommended plugin so
if you see there is a whole lot of
plugins which are bare essential plugins
that is required for Jenkins in order to
run properly so Jenkins as a part of the
installation would get all these plugins
and then install it for you this is a
good combination to kind of begin with
and mind you at this moment Jenkins
needs lots of bandwidth in in terms of
network so in case your you know your
network is not so good few of these
plugins would kind of fail and these
plugins are all you know unavailable on
openly or or mirrored sites and
sometimes some of them may be down so do
not worry in case some of these plugins
kind of fail to install you'll get an
option to kind of retry installing them
but just ensure that you know at least
most or 90 95 percent of all these
plugins are installed without any
problems let me pause the video here for
a minute and then get back once all
these plugins are installed my plug-in
the installation is all good
there was no failures in any of my
plugins so after that I get to create
his first admin user again this is one
important point that you got to remember
Keane given any user name and password
but ensure that you kind of remember
that because it's very hard to get back
your username and password in case you
forget it alright so I'm gonna create a
very very simple username and password
something that I can remember I will
that's my name and an email ID is kind
of optional but it doesn't allow me to
go ahead in case I don't so I just given
an admin and I got a password I've got I
remember my password this is my full
name all right has his same and finish
all right that kind of completed my
Jenkins installation it was not that
tough was it
that I have my Jenkins installed
correctly let me quickly walk you
through some very minimal configurations
that is required these are kind of a
first-time configuration that is
required so and also let me warn you the
UI is little hard for many people to
wrap their head around it specifically
the windows guys but if at all you're a
java guy you know how painful it is to
write UI in java you kind of appreciate
you know all the effort that has gone
into the UI bottom line he was a little
hard to you know wrap your head around
it but once you start using it possibly
you start liking it all right so let me
get into something called as managed
Incans this can be viewed like a main
menu for all Jenkins configuration so I
will get into some of those important
ones something called as configure a
system configure a system this is where
you kind of put in the configuration for
your complete Jenkins instance few
things to kind of look out for this is
the home directory
this is a Java home where all the
configurations all the workspace
anything and everything regarding
Jenkins is store out here system message
you want to put in some message on the
system he's just type in whatever you
want and he's probably show up somewhere
up here on the menu number of executors
very very important configuration
this just lets genkan know at any point
in time how many jobs or how many
threads can be run you can you can kind
of visualize it like a thread that can
be run on this particular instance as a
thumb rule if at all you're on a single
core system number of executors to
should be good enough in case at any
point in time if there are multiple jobs
that kind of get trigger at the same
time in case the number of executors are
less compared to the number of jobs that
are there to open up no need to panic
because they will all get queued up and
eventually Jenkins will get to running
those jobs just bear in mind that
whenever a new job kind of FINA gets
triggered the CPU usage and the memory
usage in terms of the disk write is very
high on the Jenkins instance so that's
something that you gotta kind of keep in
mind alright but number of executors -
for my system is kind of good label for
my Jenkins I don't want any of these
things usage how do you want to use your
Jenkins this is good for me because I
only have a primary server that is
running
so I want to use this tour as much as
possible quite prayer each of these
options have got some bare minimal help
kind of a thing that is there is out
there by clicking on these question
marks you will get to know as to what
are these particular configurations all
right so this all look good what I want
to show you here is something regarding
the darker time stamps kit plugin
Isthmian email notifications I don't
want that what I want the yeast
I want this SMTP server configuration
remember I mentioned earlier that I
would want Jenkins to be sending out
some emails and what I've done here is
I've just configured the SMTP details of
my personal email ID in case you are in
know in organization you would have some
sort of an email ids that is set up for
a Jenkins server so you can specify the
SMTP server details of your company so
that you know you can authorize Jenkins
to kind of send out emails but in case
you wanna try it out like we I have
configured my personal email id which is
on my Gmail for sending out
notifications so the same TP server
would be smtp.gmail.com using the SMTP
authentication I have provided my email
ID and my password I'm using SMTP port
which is 465
and I'm you know reply to address is the
same as mine I can just send out an
email and see if at all this
configuration works again Gmail would
not allow you to allow anybody to send
out notifications on your behalf so
you'll have to lower the security level
of your gmail ID so that you can allow
programmatically somebody to send out
email notifications on your behalf so
I've done already that I'm just trying
to see if I can send a test email with
the configurations that I've set in
yes all right so the email configuration
looks good so this is how you configure
your you know your Gmail account in case
you want to do that if not put in your
organisation SMTP server details which
are for the valid username and password
and should all be set all right so no
other configuration that I'm going to
change here all of these look good
all right so I come back to managing
Ken's okay one other thing that I want
to kind of goal is the global tool
configuration imagine this scenario look
at it this way
Jenkins is a is a continuous integration
server it doesn't know what kind of a
codebase it's gonna pull in what kind of
a tool says there is required or what is
the code that is gonna pull in and how
is it gonna build so you will have to
put in all the tools that is required
for building the appropriate kind of
code that you're gonna pull in from you
know your source code repositories so
this to you an example in case your
source code is a Java source code and
assuming that you know because in this
demo this is my laptop and I put in all
the configurations GDK everything on my
laptop because I am a developer I am
working on the laptop but my country's
integration server would be you know a
separate server without anything being
installed on it so in case I want
Jenkins to you know run a Java Cole I
would need to install JDK on it I need
to specify the JDK location of this out
here this way
okay since I already have the JDK
installed and have already put in the
Java whom directly or rather and the
environment variable correctly I don't
need to do it get if at all I want the
Jenkins server to use git git is a you
know command bash or the command prompt
for for running git and connecting to
any other git server so you would need
get to be you know installed on that
particular system and set the path
accordingly Gradle and mavin if at all
you have some Mavin's as well you want
to do this any other tool that you're
gonna install on your system which is
your continuous integration server you
will have to come in here and configure
something in case you don't configure it
when shinkansen runs it will not be able
to find these tools for building your
tasks and it will crib about it
that's good I don't want to save
anything managing canes let me see what
else is required yes configure global
security
is enabled and if you see by default
it's the security access control is set
to Jenkins own user database so what
does this mean
you know Jenkins by default it uses
filesystem where it stores all the user
names which hashes up these user names
and kind of stores them so as of now it
jenkins is configured to use its own
database assuming that you are running
in an organization you would probably
want to have a you know some sort of an
ad or an LDAP server using which you
would want to control access to your
jenkins repository rather jenkins tune
so you would specify your LDAP server
details the root DN password or the
manager DN and the manager password and
all these details in case you want to
connect your Jenkins instance with your
LDAP or AD or any of the authentication
servers that you have in your
organization but for now since I don't
have any of these things I'm going to
use this own database that's good enough
all right so I will set up some
authorization methods and stuff like
that once I put in few jobs so for now
let me not get into any of these details
of this just be aware that Jenkins can
be connected for authorization to an
LDAP server or you can have Jenkins
managing its own servers which is
happening as of now so I'm going to save
all this stuff that's good for me so
enough of all these configurations let
me put in a very very simple job all
right so job new item you know little
difficult to kind of figure out but then
that's the new item so I will just say
you know first job this was good for me
I just give a name for my job I would
say it's a freestyle project that's good
enough for me I don't want to choose any
of that so unless until you choose any
of this this particular button would not
become active so choose the freestyle
project and say okay
at a very high level you would see
general source code management bill
triggers beta environment build and post
build in case you install more and more
plugins you will see lot more options
but for now this is what you would see
so what am i doing at the moment I'm
just putting up a very very simple job
and the job could be anything and
everything so I don't want to put in a
very complicated job for now for the
demo but paas let me just put in a very
very simple job I'll give a description
this is an optional thing this is my
first Jenkins job alright I don't want
to choose any of these again there are
some helps available here
I don't want to choose any of this I
don't want to connect it to do any
source code for now I don't want any
triggers for now I'll come back to this
in in a while Billie environment I don't
want any build environment as a part of
this build step you know I just want to
you know run few things so that I kind
of complete this particular job so since
I'm one of Windows box I would say
execute windows batch command alright so
what do you want to do I would let me
just echo something echo
hello this is my first Jenkins job and
possibly I would want the deed and the
timestamp
pertaining to the job I mean the date
and time in which this job was wrong all
right very very simple command that says
you know this is my first job it just
puts out something along with the date
and the time all right I don't want to
do anything else I want to keep this job
as simple as this so let me save this
job all right
so once you save this job you know the
job names comes up here and then I need
to build this job and he would see some
bill history out here nothing is there
as of now because I've just put in a job
I have not run it yet all right so let
me try to build it now
you see a big number you will see a date
and a timestamp so if I click on this
you'll see a console output if I go here
okay as simple as that and where is all
the job details that is getting into if
you see this
to this particular directory all right
so this is the directory what I was
mentioning earlier regarding Jenkins
home so all the job related stuff that
is specific to this particular Jenkins
installation is all here
all the plugins that is installed the
details of each of those plugins can be
found here all right
so the workspace is where all the jobs
that I've created which ever I'm running
would you know there will be individual
folders specific to the jobs that has
been put up here all right so one job
one quick run that's what it looks like
pretty simple
okay let me do one thing let me put up a
second job
can job
it's a freestyle project
all right this is my second job
I just want to demonstrate the
powerfulness of the automation server
and how simple it is to automate a job
that is put up on Jenkins
which will be triggered automatically
remember what I said earlier about
Jenkins because at the core of Jenkins
is a very very powerful automation
server alright so what I'm gonna do I
will just keep everything else the same
I'm gonna put in a belt scrape prima
similar to second job that gets
triggered automatically every minute all
right let me do that
percentage date and now put in the time
alright so I just put in on the job
called second job and it pretty much
does the same thing as what I was doing
earlier in terms of putting the date and
the time but this time I am just going
to demonstrate the powerfulness of the
automation server that is there if you
see here there's a bill trigger so a
build can be triggered using various
triggers that is there so we'll get into
this github triggering or hook or a web
hook kind of a triggering later on but
for now what I want to do I want to
ensure that this job that I'm going to
put in would be automatically triggered
on its own let's say every minute I'm on
this job to be run on its own so will
periodically is my setting if you see
here there's a bunch of help that is
available for me so for those of you
you've written cron jobs on Linux boxes
you'll find it very very simple but for
others don't panic
let me just put up a very very simple
regular expression for scheduling this
job every minute all right so that's 1 2
3 4 5
Rick come up come up come up
so five stars is all that I'm gonna put
in and Jenkins got a little worried and
she's asking me do you really mean every
minute or yeah I wanna do this every
minute let me save this and how do I
check whether he gets triggered every
minute or not I just don't do anything
but just wait for a minute and if at all
everything goes well Jenkins would
automatically trigger my second job in a
minutes time from now
Demerol I'm not gonna trigger anything
look they see it's automatically got
trigger
if I go in here yep second job that gets
triggered automatically you know it was
triggered at 42 1642 which is 442 my
time that looks good
and if everything goes well every one
minute onwards this job would be
automatically triggered now that I have
my Jenkins up and running a few jobs
that has been put up here on my Jenkins
instance I would need a way of
controlling access to my Jenkins server
this is where in I would use a plugin
called role based access plugin and
create few rules the rules are something
like a global rule and a project rule
for a specific role I can have different
rules and I can have users who have
signed up or the users for my create
kind of assigned to these roles so that
each of these users fall into some
category this is my way of kind of
controlling access to my Jenkins
instance and ensuring that people don't
do something unwarranted alright so
first things first let me go ahead and
install a plugin for doing that so I get
into manage Jenkins and manage plug-in a
little bit of a confusing screen in my
opinion there is updates available
installed in advance as of now we don't
have the role-based plugin so let me go
to available it'll take some time for it
to get refreshed
alright now these are the available
plugins these are the installed plugins
alright so let me come back to available
and I will want to search for my role
based access plugin so I would say
search for role and hit enter
okay role-based authorization strategy
enables user authorization using a role
based strategy roles can be defined
globally or for particular jobs or
no-sew and stuff like that so exactly
this is the plugin that I want I would
want to install it without early start
right looks good so far yes go back to
the top of the page yes I remember
Jenkins is running on a Java using a
Java instance so typically many things
would work the same way unless
inherently you want to restart Jenkins
once in a while but as a good practice
whenever you do some sort of big
installations or big patches on your
Jenkins instance just ensure that you
can have restart it otherwise there
would be a difference in terms of what
is installed on the system and what is
there on the file system you will need
to flush out few of those settings later
on but for now these are all very small
plugins so these would run without any
problems but otherwise if at all there
are some plugins which they would need a
restart
you know kindly go ahead and restart
your Jenkins instance but for now I
don't need that it looks good I have
installed the plug-in so where do I see
my plug-in I install the plug-in that is
specific to the user control or the
access control so let me go into yes
global security and I would see this
role based out of these showing up now
all right so this comes in because of my
installation of my role-based plugin so
this is what I would want to enable
because I already have my own database
setup and for the authorization part in
the sense that who can do what I am
going to install I mean I've already
installed a role based strategy plug-in
and I'm going to enable that strategy
all right I would say save okay
now I've installed the role based access
plug-in I would need to just set it up
and check that you know I would go ahead
and create some roles and it show that I
assign uses as per these roles all right
so let me go to managing canes configure
all right let me see where is this
configure configure global security is
that where I create my roles
nope not here
yes managing assigned roles
okay again you would see these options
only after you install these plugins so
for now I've just enabled the plug-in I
have enabled role-based access control
and I would go ahead and create some
rules for this particular Jenkins
instance so I would say first manage
rules
so I would need to create some roles
here and the roles are at a very high
level these are global rules and there
are some project roles and there are
some slave roles I'll not get into
details of all of this at a very very
high level which is a global role let me
just create a role a role can be kind of
visualize like a group so I would create
our own called developer typically the
Jenkins instance or the CA instance are
kind of owned up or controlled by QA
guys so QA guys would need to provide
some sort of you know limited access to
developers so that's why I am creating a
rule called developer and I'm adding
this role at a global role level so I
would say and this here and you would
see this develop a rule that is there
and each of these options you can fig
[ __ ] over it you would see some sort of
a help on what what are these you know
permissions specific to so what I want
is like you know it sounds a little you
know different but I would want to give
very very little permissions for the
developer so from an administration
perspective I would just want him to
have a read kind of a rule credentials
again I would just want a view kind of a
rule I don't want him to create any
agents and all that stuff that's good
for me for a job I would want him to
just possibly read I don't want him to
build I don't want him to cancel any
jobs I don't want him to configure any
job I don't even want him to create any
job I would just want him to read
through things I would not give him
possibly a role to the workspace as well
I mean I don't want him to have access
to the workspace I would just want him
to read a job Oh check you know have
read-only access to the job run no I
don't want him to give him any any
particular axis which will allow him to
run any jobs view configure yeah
possibly create yeah delete I don't want
to read yes definitely and this is the
specific role so what I'm doing I'm just
creating a global role called developer
and I'm giving him very very limited
roles in the sense that I don't want
this developer to be able to run any
agents nor create jobs or build jobs or
cancel jobs or configure jobs at the max
I just want him to read
that is already put up there okay so I
would save now I created a rule I still
don't have any users that is there on
the system so let me go ahead and create
some user on the system
that's not here how to configure
managing canes manage users okay let me
create a new user I would call this user
as developer one sounds good
some password some password that I can
remember okay
his name is developer 1d8 t.com or
something like that
okay so this is that mean with with
which I kind of configured our part of
the system and developer one is a user
that I have configured so still have not
set any rules for this particular user
yet so I would go to manage and gains I
would say manage and assign roles I
would say assign roles
okay so if you see what I'm gonna do now
is assign a role that is specific to
that particular girl I will find the
particular user and assign him
the developer role that I have already
configured the rule shows up here I
would need to find my user whoever
created and then assign him to that
particular rule so if you remember the
user that I created was developer one I
would add this particular user and now
this particular user what kind of a role
I want him to have because this is the
global rule that had created so
developer I would assign this developer
one to this particular global rule and I
would go ahead and save my changes now
let me check the permissions of this
particular user by logging out of my
admin account and logging back as
developer one
if you remember this role was created
with very less privileges so there you
go
I have Jenkins but I don't see a new
item I can't trigger a new job I can't
do anything I see these jobs however I
don't think so I'll be able to start
this job I don't have the permission set
forth at the maximum I can do is look at
the job see what was there as a part of
the concern of port and stuff like that
so this is a limited role that was
created and I added this developer to
that particular role which was a
developer role so that the developers
don't get to configure any of the jobs
because the Jenkins instance is owned by
a QA person he doesn't want to give
developer any ethnicity of Rights so the
rights that he set out by creating a
developer role and anybody who is tagged
any user who's tagged as a part of this
developer role would get the same kind
of permissions and these permissions can
be you know fine grain it can be a
project specific permissions as well but
for now I just demonstrated the high
level permission that I had set in
let me quickly log out of this user and
get back as the admin user because I
need to continue with my demo with the
developer role that was created I have
very very less privileges one of the
reasons for Jenkins being so popular as
I mentioned earlier is the bunch of
plugins that is provided by users or
community users who don't charge any
money for these plugins but it's got
plugins for connecting anything and
everything so if you can navigate to or
if we can find Jenkins plugins
you would see index of over so many
plugins that is there all of these are
wonderful plugins whatever connectors
that you would need if you want to
connect Jenkins to and the AWS instance
or you want to connect Jenkins to a
docker instance or any of those
containers you would have a plug-in you
can go and search up if I want to
connect Jenkins to big bucket weight
bucket is one of the kit servers so many
plugins then is available okay so bottom
line Jenkins
without plugins is nothing so plugins is
the heart of Jenkins for you to connect
or for in order to connect Jenkins with
any of the containers or any of the
other tool sets you would need the
plugins if you want to connect or you
want to build a repository which has got
Java and mavin you would need to install
mavin and JDK on its inconsistence if at
all you're looking for a dotnet build or
a Microsoft build you would need to have
MS build installed on your on your
Jenkins instance and the plugins that
will trigger msbuild if at all you want
to listen to some server-side web hooks
from github you would need get up
specific plugins you want to connect
Jenkins to AWS you need those plugins if
you want to connect to a docker instance
that is running anywhere in the world as
long as you have the URL which is
publicly reachable you just have a
darker plug-in that is installed on your
Jenkins instance sonar cube is one of
the popular static code analysis so you
can connect a Jenkins build you can
build a job on Jenkins and push it to
sonar cube and get sonar cube to run
analysis on that and get back the
results in Jenkins all of these works
very well because of the plugins now
with that let me connect our Jenkins
instance to github I already have very
very simple Java repository up on my
github instance so let me connect
Jenkins to this particular github
instance and pull out a job that is put
up there alright so this is my very very
simple you know repository that is there
called hello Java and this is what is
there in the repository say hello hello
dot java application that is here or a
simple class file that is there it's got
just one line of system dot out so this
is already present on github.com at this
place and this would be the URL for this
repository
if I pick up the HTTP URL this is my
strippers URL so what I would do is I
would connect my Jenkins instance to go
to github provide my credentials and
pull out this repository which is on the
cloud hosted the github calm and get it
to my Jenkins instance and then build
this particular Java file
I've keeping the source code very very
simple it's just a Java file how do I
build my Java file how do I compile my
Java file I just say Java C and the name
of my class file is hello Java and how
do I run my Java file I would say Java
and hello okay so remember I don't need
to install any plugins now because what
it needs is a get plugin so if you
remember when we were doing the
installation there was a bunch of
recommended plugins so kate is already
installed on my system so I don't need
to install it again so let me put up a
new job here this is a good job it
should be a freestyle project that's
good for me I would say okay
all right so the source code management
remember in the earlier examples we did
not use any source code because we were
just putting up some echo kind of jobs
did not need any integration with any of
the source code systems so now let me
connect this so I'm going to put up a
source code and it would show up because
the plug-in is already there it's fine
perforce any of those additional source
code management tools if at all you
would need just install those plugins
and Jenkins connects wonderfully well to
all this particular source control tools
okay so I would copy the HTTP URL from
here I would say this is the URL that
I'm supposed to go and grab my source
code from but all right that sounds good
but what is the username and password so
I'll have to specify a username and
password alright so I would say the
username this is my username and this is
my HTTP credential for my job ok so this
is my username and this is my password I
just save this and say add and then I
would say you know use these credentials
to go to github and then on my behalf
pull out a repository alright if at all
at this stage if there's any errors in
terms of not able to Jenkins not able to
find gate or the get dot exe or if my
credentials are wrong somewhere down
here you would see a red message saying
that you know something is not right you
can just go ahead and kind of fix that
for now this looks good for me I'm gonna
grab this URL what am I gonna do
the step would pull the source code from
the github and then what would be there
as a part of my build step because this
repository just has a Java file correct
hello Java so in order to for me to
build this I would just say execute
windows batch command and I would say
Java C hello dot Java that is the way I
would build my java core and if I have
to run it I would just say Java hello
pretty simple
two steps and this would run after the
repository contents are fetched from
github so Java C Java that sounds good I
would say save this and let me try to
run this okay if you see there's a lot
of you know it executed skit on your
behalf it goes out here it provides my
credentials and says you know it pulls
all my repository and by default it will
pull up the master branch that is there
on my posit ring and it kind of builds
this whole thing Java C hello to Java
and it runs this project Java hello and
there you see this is the output that is
there and if at all you want to look at
the contents of the repository if you
can go here this is mine
workspace of my system hang on this is
not right okay good job if you see here
this is my hello Java this is the same
program that was there on my github
repository
okay so this is a program that was there
on github repository alright so this was
the same program that was here and
Jenkins on our behalf
went over all the way to github pulled
this repository from there and then you
know it brought it down to my local
system on my Jenkins instance it
compiled it and it ran this particular
application okay now that I've
integrated Jenkins successfully with get
out for a simple in the java application
let me build a little bit on top of it
what I will do is I have a maven based
web application that is up there as a
repository in my github so this is the
repository that I'm talking about
it's called AMA and web app it's got its
a mavin based repository as we would
know mavin is a very very simple java
based build tool that will allow you to
run various targets and it'll compile it
will based upon the goals that you
specify it can compile it can run some
tests and it can you can build a war
file and even deploy it into some other
server for now what we gonna use maven
is just for building and creating a
package out of this particular web
application it contains a bunch of
things and what is important is just the
index dot JSP it just contains an HTML
file that is there as a part of this web
application so from a perspective
requirements now since I'm going to
connect Jenkins with this particular
posit or e gate we already have that set
we only need two other things one is
mavin because Jenkins will use maven
so in order to use maven Jenkins would
have to have a maven installation that
is there on the Jenkins box and in this
case the thing is box is this laptop
and after I have a man installed I also
need a tomcat server tomcat is a very
very simple web server and then you can
freely download I'll let you know how to
quickly download and install the Tomcat
alright so download mavin first
at the various ways in which you can
kind of download this my own
there is zip files binary zip files and
archive file so what I've done is I've
just already downloaded my own and if
you see I unzipped it here so this is
the folder with which I have unzipped my
mavin so as you know mavin again is is a
one open-source build tool so you'll
have to sit in a few configurations and
set up the path so MVN - - version if I
specify this after I set in my path
Mammon should work and if at all I echo
him to whom which is nothing but the
variable environment variable specific
to my one hope it is already set here so
once you unzip my one just set this m2
home variable to the directory video
unzip your my one also just set the path
to this particular directory slash bin
because that is where your mavin
executables are all found all right so
that's with mavin and you know since
I've set the path and the environment
variable mavin is running perfectly fine
on my system I just verified it okay
next one is a tomcat server
download apache tomcat server 8.5 is
what I have on my system so I'm just
gonna show you where to download this
from
this way you download Tomcat server and
I already have the server downloaded
again this doesn't need any installation
I just unzip it here and it kind of has
a bin and configuration I have made some
subtle changes in the configuration
first and foremost Tomcat server also by
default runs on port 8080 swin Spee
already have our Jenkins server running
on port 8080
we cannot let don't get a run on the
same port there will be a port clash so
what I've done I have configured Tomcat
to use a different port so I forego to
this configuration file here there is a
server dot XML
let me open this up here
alright okay so this is the poor by
default it will be 8080 I have just
modified it to 8 to 81 so I've changed
the port on which my Tomcat server would
run all right so that's one chain second
change when Jenkins kind of tries to get
into my Tomcat and deploy something for
someone he would need some
authentications so that he'll be alloyed
deployment by Tomcat so for that I need
to create a user on Tomcat and provide
this user credentials to my Jenkins
instance so I would go to Tomcat users
dotted symbol file here
created a user name called deployer and
the password is deployer and I've added
a role called manager - script manager -
script will allow programmatic access to
the Tomcat server so this is the role
that is there
so using this credentials I will enable
or I'll empower Jenkins to get into my
Tomcat server and deploy my application
all right only these two things that is
required let me just start my Tomcat
server first so I get into my bin folder
I open a command prompt here and there's
a startup dot bat
it's pretty fast it just takes a few
seconds yes there you go don't get
service up and running now this is
running on port 8081 so let me just
check if that looks good
so localhost 881
okay Mike don't get
is a pairing that sounds good the user
is already configured on this that's
also fine so what I will do as a part of
my first job mavin is also installed on
my system so I'm good to use mavin as a
part of my Jenkins so I will put up a
simple job now I will say job
and bien
webapp godless for
job the skirt
okay so this will be a git repository
what is the URL of my git repository is
this guy HTTP URL okay that's this URL I
will use the credentials the old
trenches that a set up will work well
because it's the same get user that I'm
kind of connecting into all right so now
the change happens here where I after I
get this since I said this is a simple
man one repository I will have some
mavin targets to run
so the simple target first is let me run
mavin package this creates a war file
okay so in VN package is the target
package is the target so when whenever I
run this package it kind of creates it
it builds it it tests it and then
creates a package so this is all that is
required maybe let me try to save this
and let me first run this and see if it
connects well if there's any problem
with my war file or the war file gets
created properly
okay wonderful so it built a war file
and if you see it all shows you what is
the location where this war file was
generated
so this is will be the workspace to see
this this warfare he was successfully
bait now I need to grab this particular
war file and then I would need to deploy
it into Tomcat server again I would need
a small plug-in to do this because I
need to connect Tomcat with my Jenkins
server let me go ahead and install the
plugin for the container deployment so I
will go to manage plugins available
type in containers
continue to continue
deploy to container okay so this would
these the plugin that I would need I
will install it without a restart right
seems to be very fast
not sorry it's still installing
okay it installed the plugin so if at
all you see this if you go to my
workspace
okay in the target folder
I won't see this web application warfare
net it's already bailed so I would need
to configure this plugin to pull up this
war file and deploy it onto the Tomcat
server for deploying under the Tomcat
server I will use the current shells of
the user that I've created okay so let
me go to configure this particular
project again and okay all this is good
so the package is good I'm gonna just
create a package that's all fine now
I had a post build step so after the war
file is built as a part of this package
your directive let me use this
deployment to container now if this will
show up after you install the plugin so
deploy this one to the container now
what is that you're supposed to specify
you're supposed to specify the what is
the location okay so this is a global
you know configuration that is there
that will allow you to
from the root folder it will pick up the
war file that is there so star star four
slash star dot war that's good for me
okay what is the context path context
path is nothing but just the name of an
application that you know under which it
will get deployed into the Tomcat server
but I will just say ma and web app
that's the name of my thing now I need
to specify what kind of a container that
I am talking about all right so the
deployment would be for the stunk at 8.5
is what I need okay because the server
that we have is a tomcat 8.5 server that
I have so this would be the URL so the
credentials yes I need to add a
credential for this particular server so
if you remember I had created a
credential for my web application so let
me just find that my Tomcat server
yes configuration of this
okay so deployer and deployer user name
is deployer password is deployer
okay so let me use that credential I
would say I would say add a new
credential Jenkins credential the user
name is deployer and the password is
reply
so I would use this deploy credential
that and what is the URL of my Tomcat
instance so this is the URL of my Tomcat
instance so take the word file that is
fine found in this particular folder and
then you know context bar the same in
every web use the deploy or deployment
credentials and getting to this
localhost which is there 80 81 this is
the Tomcat server that is running on my
system and then go ahead and deploy it
ok so that is all that is required so I
would say just save this and let me run
it now
okay it built successfully built the war
file it is trying to deploy it and looks
like a deployment went ahead perfectly
well so
was in being the bap if I type in this
all right if at all I go ahead into my
Tomcat server there would be a web apps
folder you would see the you know the
date/time stamp so this is the file that
get caught recently copied and this is
the Explorer version of our application
so the application was built the source
code of this application was pulled from
the github server it was built locally
on the Jenkins instance and then it was
pushed into a tomcat server which is
running on a different port which is a
it's really quite one now for this demo
I'm running everything locally on my
system but assuming that you know this
particular tomcat instance was running
on some other server with some other
different IP address all that you gotta
go and change is the URL of the server
so this would be the server in case you
you already have that you know I have a
tomcat server which is running on some
other machine that's all fine with a
different IP that's all good enough the
whole bundle or the war file that was
built as a part of this Jenkins job gets
transferred on to the other server and
gets deployed that's the beauty of
Jenkins and automatic deployments or
other deployments using Jenkins and my
own
distributed build or master slave
configuration in Jenkins as you would
have seen you know we just have one
instance of Jenkins server up and
running all the time and also I told you
that whenever any job that kind of you
know get started on the Jenkins server
it is little heavy on on in terms of
disk space and the CPU utilization so
which kind of you know if at all you're
in an organization where in you're
heavily reliant on the Jenkins server
you don't want your Jenkins server to go
down so that's where in you kind of
start distributing the load that is
there on the Jenkins server so you prime
will have a server which is just a
placeholder or like a master will take
in all the kind of jobs and what you'll
do is a based upon trigger that has
happened to the job or whichever job
needs to be built he if at all he can
delegate these jobs on to some of the
machines or some of the sleeves you know
that's a wonderful thing to have okay
use kiss want use kiss to assuming that
you know if you have a Jenkins server
that is running on a Windows box or on
Linux one and if at all you have a need
where you need to build based upon
operating systems you have multiple
build configurations to support maybe
you need to build a Windows you know
Windows based dotnet kind of a projects
where you would need a Windows machine
to build this particular project you
also have a requirement where you want
to build Linux Linux based systems you
also have a Mac you support some surfer
apps or something that is built on Mac
OS you would need to build you know Mac
based system as well so how are you
gonna support all these needs so that's
where in a beautiful concept of
master/slave our you know primary and
delegations or agent and master comes
into play so typically you would have
one Jenkins server who will just you
know configured with all the proper
authorizations users configurations and
everything is set up on this Jenkins
server his job is just delegations he
will listen to some set for triggers or
based upon the job that is coming in he
will if there is a very nice way of
delegating these jobs to somebody else
and you know taking back the results he
can control lot of other systems and
these systems may not have a complete or
there's no need to put in a complete
Jenkins installation all that you got to
do is have a very very simple Runner or
a sleeve that's a simple jar file that
is run as a low priority thread or a
process within these systems so with
that you can have a wonderful
distributed build server that can be set
up and in case one of the server's goes
down your master would know that what
went down and kind of delegate the task
to somebody else so this is the kind of
distributed build or the master slave
configuration so what I'll do in this
exercise or in this demo is I will set
up a simple slave but since I don't have
too many machines to kind of player on
what I will do is I will set up a slave
in in one other folder within my hard
drive so I've got the C Drive and D
Drive my Jenkins is on my C Drive so
what I would do is I would just use my
e try and set up a very very simple
slave out there I'll just show you how
to provision a slave and how to connect
to a slave and how to delegate a job to
that's lame let me go back to my Jenkins
master and configure him to you know
talk to an agent so there are various
ways in which this client and server
talk to each other what I'm going to
choose is something called as jnlp Java
networked launch protocol so using this
I would ensure that you know the client
and server talk to each other so for
that I need to ensure that I kind of
enable this jnlp port
so let me try to find out where is that
they will try this
okay yes agents and by default this jnlp
agents thing would be disabled so if you
see here there's a small help on this so
I'm going to use this jnlp which is
nothing but Java Network launch protocol
and you know I'll configure the master
and server to talk to each other using
gen MP so for that I need to enable this
guide so I enable this guy instead of
making the by default the configuration
was disabled so I make him random and
make him you know enabled and I say save
this configuration all right so now
configure or I made a setting for the
master so that the journal P port is
kind of opened up so let me go ahead and
you know create an agent so I go to
manage nodes so if you see here there's
only one master here
so let me provision the new node here so
this is the way you know in which you
bring up a new node you have to
configure it on the server Jenkins would
put in some sort of security around this
particular agent and let you know how to
launch this particular engine so that he
can connect to your Jenkins master so I
would say new node I would give a name
for mine or I would say Windows node
because both of these are Windows only
so that's fine I just give an identifier
saying that Windows node I would say
this is a permanent agent now say ok so
if you see the name let me just copy
this name here with the description
number of executors since it's a slave
node and both of these are running on my
system I will keep the number of
executors as one that's fine
remove root directory now this is where
let me just clarify this since I have
both my my master is running on my c
drive c drive program files 86 or not
not 86 c colon program files
it is indeed 86
all right Jenkins so this is where my
master is running so I don't want the C
Drive what I will do is I will use
something called as a drive I have
another Drive in my system but please
visualize this like you know you're
running this on a separate system
altogether so I create a folder here
called Jenkins node and this is where
I'm going to place my or I'm going to
provision my slave and I'm going to run
him from here so this is the directory
in which I am going to provision my
slave node so I'm going to copy this
here and that is the remote root
directory of your particular agent of
sleep so I just copied here the label
you know probably this is fine for me
how do you want to use this guy so I
would don't want him to run all kinds of
jobs i will only build jobs with label
expressions that match this particular
node and so this is the label of this
node so in order for somebody to kind of
delegate any task to them they have got
to specify this particular label so
imagine this way if I have a bunch of
Windows my system I named it as Windows
star anything that says from Windows I
can give a regular expression and say
that anything that matches Windows run
this particular task there if I have
some Mac machines I name all these
magazines as Mac star or something of
that and I can delegate all tasks you
know saying that start with whatever
starts with Mac and this node run the
Mac jobs there so you identify a node
using the label and then delegate the
task there all right so launch method
you know we will use Java Web Start
because we got
you got to use jnlp protocol okay that
sounds good
directory I think nothing else is
required availability yes we'll keep
this agent yep online as much as
possible that sounds good all right let
me see if this
alright I'm just provisioning this
particular node now so if I click on
this node I get a bunch of commands
along with an agent or char so this is
the agent or chart that has to be taken
down to the other machine or the slave
node and from there I need to run this
along with a small security credential
so let me copy this whole text here in
my notepad not bad plus plus is good for
me ok I copy this whole
but there I also want to download this
alien dejar I would say yes
this agent dot jar is the one that is
configured by our server so all the
details that is required for launching
this agent dot jar is found in this I'm
sorry for launching this agent is found
this agent or jar so typically I need to
take this jar file on to the other
system
and then kind of running from there so I
have this alien rod jar
I copy this or I cut this I come back to
my folder my Jenkins known I paste it
here
okay so now with this provision agent or
jar and I need to use this whole command
control a control C and then launch this
particular agent so let me bring up a
command from right here and then lost it
so I'm saying in the same folder where
this agent or jar I'm gonna launch this
particular agent Java - jar is in da jar
jnlp this is the URL of my server in
case the server and client are on
different locations or different IPS
they don't specify the IP address all
these anyway would show up
and then the secret and you know the
root folder of your Jenkins or the slave
node
okay
so something ran and then you know it
says it's connected very well it seems
to connected very well so let me come
back to my Jenkins instance and see you
know if at all you see earlier this was
not connected Lord let me refresh this
guy
okay now these two guys are connected
provision a Jenkins node and then I
copied all the credentials of this
Labrador jar along with the launch code
and then took it to the other system and
kind of ran it from there
since I don't have another system I have
just got a separate directory in another
folder another Drive and I'm launching
the agent from here as long as this
particular agent is up and running on
this command prompt is up and running
the agent would be connected so once I
close this the connection goes down
alright so successfully you've launched
this particular agent now this would be
the home directory of this Jenkins node
or the Jenkins slave so any task that
I'm going to delegate to this particular
slave would all be run here it will
create a workspace right here alright so
good so let me just come back and let me
kind of put up a new task here I will
say that you know then I get jobs good I
say first I'll project I'm going to
create a very very simple job here
I don't want it to come to gate or
anything of that let me just create a
very very simple echo
relegated to the slave we needed to I
don't like the word slave delegate it to
agent for this way
alright so delegate it to agent sounds
good now how am I gonna ensure that this
particular job runs on the agent or on
the slave that I have configured right
you see this if at all you remember how
we provision in our particular slave we
give a label right so now I'm going to
put in a job that will only match this
particular label
so I'm gonna say that whatever matches
this you know windows label run this job
on that particular node so we have only
one node that's matching this in Windows
node so this job will be delegated out
there so I save this and let me Billis
this is again a very very simple job
there's nothing in this I just want to
demonstrate how to kind of delegate it
to an agent so if you see this it ran
successfully and where is the workspace
the workspace is right inside our
Jenkins node it created a new workspace
delegate a job it put in here so my old
or the my primary master our job is in
sequel program files under Jenkins and
this is the slave job that was
successfully run very very simple but
very very powerful concept of master
slave configuration or distributed in
Jenkins okay
approaching the final section where
we've done all this hard work in
bringing a bunch in conserve were
configuring it putting up some jobs on
in creating users and all this stuff now
we don't want this configuration to kind
of go away we want a very nice way of
ensuring that we back up all this
configuration and in case there is any
failure hardware crash or a machine
crash we would want to kind of restore
from the existing configuration that the
kind of backed up the one quick way to
do that would be or one dirty way to do
that would be just you know take a
complete backup of a psycho : program
files : Jenkins directory because that's
where our holes in Kim's configuration
is present but we would don't want to do
that let's use some plugins for taking
up a backup let me go to manage Hinkins
and click on available and let me search
for somebody they're a bunch of backup
plugins so I would like one one of these
plugins that I specifically use also
this is the backup plug-in so let me go
ahead and install this plug-in
all right so we went ahead and install
this plugin so let me come back to my
manage plugins so plugin is there so
hang on backup managing so you will see
this option once you install this
plug-in so first time I can you know do
a setup I would say backup this
particular I'll give a folder this
folder is pertaining to the folder where
I want Jenkins to backup some data and I
would say the format should be zip
format is good enough let me give a name
or template or a file name for my you
know backup this is good
I won't written verbose mode I don't
want to shut on my Jenkins or should I
shut it down no okay one thing that you
got to remember is that whenever a
backup happens there are too many jobs
that is running on the server it can
kind of slow down your Jenkins instance
because it's it's the process of copying
few of those things and if the files are
being changed at that moment it's little
bit problematic for Jenkins so typically
you backup your servers only when there
is very less load or typically try to
you know bring it to a share own kind of
a state and then take a backup
alright so I'm gonna back up all these
things you know I don't want to exclude
anything else I want the history
I want demon artifacts wasn't later one
this guy I would just save and then I
would say back him up so this would run
a bunch of you know steps and all the
files that is required as a part of this
pretty fast but then if at all you have
too many things up on your server for
now we didn't have too many things up on
our server but in case you had too many
things to kind of back up this may take
a while so let me just pause this
recording and get back to you once the
backup is complete so there you go the
backup was successful created a backup
of all workspace the configurations the
users and you know all that so all this
is kind of hidden down in this
particular zip file so at any instance
if at all I kind of crashed my system
for some instance or say hard disk
failure and I bring up a new instance of
Jenkins I can kind of use the backup
plug-in for restoring this particular
configurations so how do I do that I
just come back to my management canes
come back to backup manager and I will
say restore hurts cuts and all of
Jenkins configuration now that we know
what is continuous integration and where
does Jenkins come into picture let's
look at the rest of the tasks of a
software development lifecycle so if at
all I were to visualize the kind of
steps that is involved in delivering my
software possibly the condensed
integration phase would be somewhere
here where multiple developers are
developing on that and then we have a
little bit of a stable code that is
there that can be kind of moved across
because I want to go ahead with the
particular build that I have and then I
want to migrate that I want to propagate
that across various environments so if
you consider the standard software
delivery approach in the first cycle you
just do some minimal testing and then
you kind of move that to one of the
environments and from there you kick off
more and more tests they could be
integration tests they could be
acceptance tests they could be
functionality check they could be a
stress test they could be a load test it
could be sister
integration test all kinds of tests that
you can think about and all the way
maybe propagating the build across
various environments if all this can be
considered as various steps the workflow
is such that as and when the bill moves
across various phases if there's any
failure of course the bill propagation
kind of stops everyone gets notified but
if at all everything goes well so your
workflow is progressing well and at the
end of the workflow you eventually have
a code which is pretty much good to
release now mind you I make an
assumption here that most of your test
cases are automated and you have a good
percentage of coverage of your test
cases but if that is not the scenario
then possibly there are some automated
tests or checks that may be required in
between but if the workflow can kind of
accommodate all that as well you know
you can visualize this as the steps that
is required for your software
development or a software delivery
lifecycle now in Jenkins the way this
kind of translate this is that each of
these tasks can be put out as a job so
now let me quickly I'll let you know or
let me quickly demo what existed in
region Keens 2.0 where I could put up a
couple of jobs and I can connect them
using the upstream downstream linking
mechanism so if this job one if at all
it is a bill genuine test cases if at
all that passes successfully job two
gets triggered if the job two is more
about running some more automated tests
or possibly deploying it to environment
and then kicking up some more test cases
that would be chopped but if the
deployment fails or if some of the other
test cases fail it would not propagate
to the third shope all right so let me
quickly bring up my Jenkins instance and
put up some sample jobs and tell you how
to connect that or rather how would one
connect that using Jenkins 2.0 or pre
Jenkins 2.0 release I have now brought
up my Jenkins instance and in case some
of you don't know how to install Jenkins
or you don't know how to bring up your
Jenkins instance I would strongly
recommend that you watch our previous
videos on simple and YouTube channel
where I've detailed out the steps that
is required for you to install Jenkins
and bring it up so alright sir brought
up my Jenkins instance let me put up few
of those jobs now mind you I'm going to
cover the three Jenkins 2.0
sure here all right so let me put up my
first job all right I hope I don't have
that job
I say it's a freestyle project I don't
want to change anything I'm gonna put up
a very very simple job here it's in
batch command
I say echo first job triggered at right
past my first job let me put up my
second job freestyle project alright
that's my second job
alright that's my third
got us very very simple echo statements
in this so just prints out the system
date and the time in it alright so I
could run these jobs individually if I
want so let me just check running my
third job so this is what I get and the
console output third job triggered at
date and time oops let me fix that right
so that should fix it let me check my
second job
all right that's my second job all right
so I've got three jobs now if I were to
link them together or if at all I want a
scenario where after the first job is
successful we'll run
I would like to figure my second job so
I would do a small configuration change
in here I would say after this first job
is run I want to trigger the second job
so I have something called as a post
print action so I can say that triggers
some other jobs from here so if you see
this publish record deploy all right
trigger trigger trigger trigger let me
check the other one build other projects
this is what I would want to do so after
the first job is done
I want to trigger my second job all
right I would say save this now let me
go back to my second job and then
trigger the third job after the second
job is done right I would add this post
build by other projects third job again
I'm not really sure if you guys notice
this there is various configurations as
to when exactly do you want to trigger
the other job and the default one is to
your own leave the build stable so
typically this is the configuration that
would need we definitely don't want the
third job to be trigger in case the
second job fails all right so this is
the combination that I want or this is
the choice that I want and it saved this
now I have three of my jobs if you see
this the second job the upstream job is
the first job so let me check this kind
of a pipeline what I've set here is a
very very simple pipeline so after my
first job gets triggered if I build this
guy right the second job gets triggered
after the build first job is built so if
I click on the second job alright so the
first job was to get the second job and
after the second job it is triggering
the third job so this is how first job
second job and third jobber kind of
linked but it's pretty hard to visualize
this as to you know if I need to see one
holistic picture where after the first
job after the second job after the third
job what does the flow it's not possible
for me to visualize that that's wherein
I install a plugin so let me go to
manage plugins right here I think I
already have it installed for those of
you who don't have it installed you can
go to the available button I mean
available tab and click on that the
plugin is called delivery pipeline
plug-in I already have it installed in
case you don't have it installed just go
to the
you click on this and say install
without restart this is the plug-in that
I want you to install all right so now
we have that plug-in installed so what I
want to do is after the plug-in is
installed you see something like this so
this is where I would create a new
visualization for the pipeline that I've
created so I would say my first pipeline
or I give a name for my visualization I
would say yes this upstream downstream
dependence is this exactly what I want
and there's a bunch of settings here
I'll not look at any of that now what I
want is I just want to tell this view
that you know so I can give a name for
this I would give it as simply learn
pipeline and what's important is that I
specify what is the first job that
should be picked up as a part of this
pipeline and the final job is optional
because it knows that if the first job
is triggering this other job it knows
where to end this whole lifecycle so I
define a pipeline and you give a name
for my component and initialize that as
my I mean I give it the first job so I
say ok and there you go this is much
better this gives you a beautiful
visualization of as to what happened
after the first job second job was run
second job if you click on any of these
that will in fact take me to that shop
alright there is also one other option
which is pretty good option in my
opinion which is about edit view yes
this is where it is and it will start
off a new pipeline build let me apply
and let me click OK on this what it
gives me is a way in which I can trigger
my whole pipeline from here so if I
click on this there you see the first
job getting trigger the second job is
still running the green means it's it's
all run properly and nicely second one
is trigger now the third one it's still
running all right so this is the
pipeline that existed prior to Jenkins
2.0 this is pretty decent enough and if
you see there's a one-to-one mapping but
if at all you remember we could go and
add multiple dependencies for the
projects that I set in just to give an
example and so if I go to my first job I
can do a configuration here and nothing
stops me from triggering multiple jobs
after this by giving the comma I can
trigger multiple jobs here in case if I
have to run few things parallely this
also gives me that option to do that but
having said that this was the most
primitive way in which the jobs were
kind of visualized and run
prior to Jenkins 2 or 0 now this feature
became such an important feature the
users wanted more and more complicated
because the pipeline's was no lot
complicated it was not just one job
after the other they were multiple job
that has to be run and there is also an
introduction of the Jenkins agents where
multiple tasks could be parallel to run
on different agents so they wanted to
Club all of that and the pipeline could
have all the such complicated stuff
that's where in post genkan toward 0 odd
in Jenkins 2.0 Jenkins are released a
version which has got the feature of
pipeline which can be written in groovy
scripts the groovy is fun a full
scripting language it's very very
powerful
anybody can visualize your pipeline or
write your pipeline using programming
language and the point of everything is
code where this whole groovy script gets
into your source code repository so
instead of putting jobs here and in case
my Jenkins kind of fails you know
there's a crash on my Jenkins I don't
get back this job's how do I bring back
all these jobs back
so everything is good that's the DevOps
principle so the pipelines will be
written as scripts that is what I'm
gonna do in my next exercise in my
previous example I showed you the crude
way in my opinion of putting up a
Jenkins pipeline but this is what
existed prior to Jenkins 2.0 and now I
have post Jenkins 2.0 in terms of my
ocean Jenkins motion it's 2.10 7 so this
supports something called as the
scripted pipeline wherein you can write
your pipeline in terms of groovy scripts
no need to put up any jobs here and
remember how exactly you put up these
individual jobs you can write a pipeline
script in terms of groovy language let
me quickly show you a very very simple
and elementary pipeline that I have this
is what a groovy script would look like
pipeline any agent can run this stages
there are individual stages that is
defined as a subset of these stages so
the first stage is the compile stage and
stage has got some steps in it you can
have multiple steps in it and once only
after all this steps successfully
complete that's where in the stage gets
through perfectly with with the pass so
there's a compile a stage there's a
j-unit stage there's a quality gate
stage there's a deploy stage
really not doing anything much within
this other than echoing you know some
text within each of these stages and
what's interesting is at the end there's
something called as a post which is
similar to our you can kind of equate
that to what would be there in a
try-catch kind of a block supposed
always meaning this would run all the
time
success only if at all all the steps
that were above in terms of the stages
they were completed successfully without
any failures so typically you'll have
your email that is going out here saying
that the build is successful and stuff
like that failure if something went bad
if any of the step resulted in a failure
this particular block will get executed
unstable whenever any build is marked
unstable if at all only few things that
fail within your test run and you would
want to mark the build as unstable I
changed this is an interesting option so
this compares the present run with the
previous run and if there's any change
meaning if the previous run was a
failure and the present run is a success
or vice-versa
this would get triggered so this is what
a simple pipeline script would look like
so let me copy this pipeline and let me
put up a simple job for running this
pipeline so let me open up my Jenkins
say a new I would say scripted pipeline
yeah this is one at one I don't want to
choose a freestyle project this is going
to be a pipeline project so I would say
pipeline and say okay all right this has
got far less options than the other
chops that we put up so general I don't
want anything here I don't want Annabel
trigger right so this is where I kind of
I can paste in whatever I had copied
there's also something called as a
pipeline syntax or syntax generator this
is like a lookup where you can choose
what you want to do and choose the
option that is specific to those steps
and you will get a pipeline generated or
a script generated for you Jenkins knows
that you're not very good at
understanding these pipelines so this
gives you this sandbox kind of an
environment where you can check out
whatever you want to do as a part of
your pipeline and then get the
equivalent groovy script from here let
me look at this in a bit later so for
now I have my pipeline syntax already
copied so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
paste when I copied all right so this
looks good okay
I'm not connecting to any native
repository of any of that I'm just
running a very very simple pipeline
which has got some steps in it and it
just compiles or rather it just puts out
some messages saying that this ditch
completed successfully and stuff like
that so let me save this and let me try
to run this scripted pipeline alright if
you see this you'll see each of those
steps going through and if at all I look
at the console output compiled
successfully unit passed all the stages
passed there was a pause the failures
doesn't show up you will see the
messages from our post or the try-catch
block that I was mentioning earlier so
this is how one would put up a pipeline
and you also get to see the visualized
view of your pipeline that says which
stage run after which phase how much
time did it take and you can click on
any of these and get into looking at the
logs from that particular pipeline front
that was pretty easy wasn't it now let
me give you another scenario for a
pipeline where in the source code of my
pipeline would be in the github
repository and I will write scripts to
grab this particular code and run some
part of the code which is there as a
part of the repository so let me look at
the repository that I have I have a
repository out here on the simple on
github account which is called the
pipeline script and if you see in there
there are a bunch of batch files that
are there
so the first batch file would be a bad
batch so there's nothing in it except
that it is just trying to build a
particular project you can visualize
this as individual batch files which
actually contain the scripts for
building running deploying and checking
the quality gate of your particular
project so I have a couple of batch
files that is here and this is on the
github repository so I would need to
write Jenkins job to log in to my github
account and then check out this
particular repository from my account
and then I run these batch files as a
part of those individual steps within
within the scripted pipeline so let me
check as to how I could do that
let me put up a new project for this let
me call this scripted pipeline scripted
pipeline from github
alright so let this be a pipeline
project that's good enough for me
let me see my scripts all right now this
is where I need to put in the scripts
for pulling out the code repository from
my github server and running those batch
files that are there as a part of the
repository so what I want to do is I
already have the skeleton of my pipeline
that is written which is very similar to
whatever was the pipeline syntax that I
showed you in the previous step so I
just copy this out here and then paste
it here so what I have here is I have
written on the high-level skeleton
without really putting in the actual
steps required for checking out rather
or rather running those build scripts so
I've got four steps one is the git
checkout step in the build step unit
test quality gate and possibly the
deployment all right so I need to put in
the actual scripts that is required for
first checking out the repository from
my github server so this is where I will
make use of this pipeline syntax so as I
mentioned earlier you have a bunch of
help that is available for you to figure
out the actual scripts that is required
for you to write within your pipeline so
what I wanted to do is check out
something from get so it's get related
so search on gate and you'll find this
option so I got a specify my git
repository URL and my credentials so let
me look at the repository URL this would
be my repository URL so let me copy this
I'm gonna copy the HTTP URL of my
repository and branch is good and one
thing that you got to notice is for now
the repository is anyway a public
repository on github so even though if I
don't specify any credentials that work
for me still but in case you have a
repository which needs strictly a
username and password to be specified
you can kind of pad it out here using
add jankins and you can give your user
name and password out here but for now I
don't need any of these things so I'm
gonna just say git checkout or rather
the URL of my repository and what we
want is the master branch for now I have
only one branch on my github server so
this is good for me so this is what
exactly I want to do as a part of the
script so if I click this this is the
script that I need to put in my build
script so I come over here and this is
what will check out the code for my
repository all right so now once I get
my code onto my repository from my
repository
it will grab those coal all these patch
files and get it on to my Jenkins
workspace now I allowed to run these
batch files as a part of each of my step
so let me look at what would be the
syntax so the first one that I want to
run would be my Bailey dot bat all right
so I want to run a batch file all right
and what is the name of the batch file
that I want run I want to run this bill
dot back
so gen direct pipeline script this is
all that I got to specify as a part of
my build step and then unit tests I kind
of just change this the unit think
that's what I have in my repository okay
that is unit and then deploy and quality
she'll capital quality and this one
would be deploy all right so this piece
of code will actually get into my
repository and check out my source code
and grab it and take it to the Jenkins
workspace so from this workspace since
all the files are there in the root
directory of this workspace it will run
these batch files one after the other
all right let me save this and let me
try to run my pipeline
all right so it
a lot of things in the background trying
to get the source code from my
repository whoa that was fast
all right so it pulled out all the
source code from my repository the last
commit message from where the source
code was pulled out there was this
create deploy not bad that looks good
I'm saying building checked out project
building the checked out project this is
what I had in my Billy not bad if I'm
not mistaken okay building the project
that's just what is there with the time
stamp running unit test cases unit dot
back it is running the unit not bad and
then giving me the date end times time
okay so all these kind of paths and if I
go back to the project I will also see
this beautiful view of how exactly what
is the time that was taken for checking
out the repository running the build on
bad running the unit test cases quality
gates and all this isn't that pretty
simple now let me modify my previous job
or rather let me put up a new job for
making use of an agent
wherein I could delegate a job to an age
in typically agents can be brought up on
any other remote machines other than
where your primary Jenkins server is
running in case you don't know or you
don't know how to start up this agents I
would strongly recommend that you refer
to our previous Jenkins video on the
simply learn youtube channel alright so
let me just check the status of my agent
for now yes he's offline so let me start
this agent because agent is not running
so I have the agent set up in my sequel
on agents so let me copy the script file
and is required for starting my agent
let me go to the agents folder command
prompt and let me try to bring up my
agent right so the agent is up and
running for now I don't have the luxury
of starting my agent on a different
machine so my agent is running on mice
on the same machine but the agents
workspace is see : agent while my
primary Jenkins server is running has
the workspace out Cheers
see colon program files 86 and this is
the workspace of my Jenkins alright I
hope you can kind of differentiate those
two all right
so now what I want is I look
the same job that I'd put in earlier or
rather modify that let the steps be the
same but I don't want to run that on my
master server let me try to delegate
that using the script so let me put up
an agent script a job right it will be a
pipeline rep job you'll say ok and let
me copy this was a step that I had put
in for my previous job so agent any so
what I'm gonna do now is I don't want
this to be running on any other agent I
want this to be running on the agent
whose label is let me check what is the
label of my agent that is running okay
so this is the name of my agent okay
Windows not so let me just copy that
there alright so with a very subtle
change instead of saying agent any I'm
going to run or rather I'm going to
specify the agent would be running this
job is the one was caught the label as
Windows not so this agent that I brought
on my system has got the name as Windows
node and it is configured to pick up any
job that matches the label to which any
job is kind of delegated so let me come
back to my jobs well is my scripted
agent job I've got too many jobs running
all right so this is my agent scripted
job that I left half way through so here
in the pipeline what I'm gonna do is yes
this is all I'm gonna need
so the job remains the same he check out
is gonna check out from same repository
I run the batch files accordingly but
this change is just to ensure that this
job is kind of delegated on the agent
alright so this would be my agent job
let me save this let me get back to the
dashboard and let me run it from here if
we see this you know the master and
agent are both idle as of now let me try
to run this agent scripted show alright
so the agent kind of kicked in and there
was a job that was delegated to the
agent if I look at what is there in the
console outboard he's pretty much doing
whatever was there as a part of the job
but the interesting thing to notice that
this is the
you workspace rather this is delegated
to the agent and the agents workspace is
this particular folder so this is where
it's gonna get all this stuff run the
whole thing and you know the flow is
pretty much the same the only thing is
this whole thing ran on the agent if I
need to check my agent I would see the
workspace out here agent scripted job if
you look at this all the batch files are
here and this is where the job was kind
of delegated to run so with the very
subtle change in Indic scripting i can
ensure that the jobs are kind of
delegated on to the agent the pipeline
job specifically as I mentioned earlier
Jenkins provides you two different ways
of writing pipelines called the scripted
and they declarative the first one that
was launched was the scripted pipeline
this is heavily based on groovy
scripting since Jenkins ships along with
the groovy engine so this was the first
script or the first support for pipeline
that was provided by Jenkins in 2.0 this
needs a little bit of a learning curve
since groovy is a wonderful script
understanding that may be a little
cumbersome but then once you kind of
master it you can write really powerful
scripts based on groovy at a very high
level this is what a typical scripted
pipeline would look like something
called as a note node represents the
agent or the actual box on which your
job would be running and then a bunch of
stages are put out which each of the
stage along with the steps that needs to
be covered as the part of those stages
listed one below the other
so all these stages if they run
peacefully then the whole task is kind
of marked as run successfully since
understanding groovy or learning ruby
was a little tough for many of the
people so this is a new one from Jenkins
where and it provides you a much simple
and friendly syntax for writing
pipelines without really needing to
understand or without needing to learn
some groovy scripting again there's a
very subtle change between these and you
there are a lot of lookups for figuring
out what is a better pipeline for you to
kind of write but if you can figure out
the difference or if you can try to find
that particular piece of code which kind
of helps you out with your pipeline
either of the scripts there's not really
any difference
in writing or kind of delivering your
pipeline using either of these two
methods alright so the clear pipeline is
something like this where you have an
agent you can specify the agent label or
if you can say agent any it will pick up
whatever is an available agent and run
the job and then you have something
called a stages stages is nothing but a
collection of stage and stage could have
multiple steps so defined within this so
if any of the steps in any of the stage
fails then that particular complete
stage and the build is marked as failure
so very subtle difference between both
these two syntax but using either of
these you can write powerful huh scripts
for your pipeline now let me come up
with an example where I'm going to at
least demo one of the feature where you
could run a master and a slave job in
parallel so let me come up with a demo
for that particular scenario
let me put up a new job for my isn't
pipeline let me call this and this would
be a pipeline project I don't want
anything here let me look at the
pipeline script that I have pipeline
agent none stages and there's a first
stage where this would be a kind of non
parallel stage where there's a need for
you to possibly pull out the source code
from one of the repositories and
possibly unit test it if all the unit
test cases pass then possibly you want
to deploy it to one of the test
environments that would be what would be
there as a part of a non parallel stage
and then you may have a bunch of tests
that could be run and assuming that you
know you have a Windows node you have a
Linux node you have some other kind of
an operating system based known you
could run these stages in parallel so
forth just for demonstration I've just
put in two parallel stages in parallel
is the keyword that you're gonna use for
running just paddling so I would say
parallel stage test on Windows and I'm
going to run this in my Windows node
well I could run a bunch of steps that
have want out here and then in the other
stage or other step what I want is I
will run something else on on my master
as long as this parallel keyword is
encountered Jenkins will ensure that
these two stages are run parallel II for
now I have both these things running on
the same machine but assuming that these
were running on different boxes you
kind of visualize it as these two steps
are going to be started paralleling
without really any dependency on each
other and then you could wait for the
test results and then based upon whether
both of these steps passed or failed
with one of them failed then we could
kind of mark the build accordingly so
let me copy this pretty pretty simple
script let me put this out here and now
let me save this out and I didn't try to
pull this all right there you go the
stage will be executed first this is a
non perilous day that's gonna happen
then the task one non agent task one one
master followed by as I said since I
have only one note or rather one system
one with both these things are running
simultaneously you not really see a
benefit of this but assuming that you
have couple of boxes on which you have
multiple agents running you possibly
want to run your selenium tests on the
windows box because selenium brings up
some of those UI which needs a browser
he could possibly need some regression
test that could run on Linux boxes or
Linux agents and then you can kind of
break down your tasks into multiple
things that is running on multiple
systems at the same time and then
collate all the results okay one final
thing all right now I have all my
particular job or rather the steps
required for my pipeline put down in in
terms of the scripts and this is saved
in this particular job that's not a good
or a recommended approach so what I'll
do is I'll copy all of these steps out
here and then what needs to be done is
actually let's say let me go back to
this repository the most preferred
approach is where you create something
called as a Jenkins file
Jenkins file and you paste all the
scripts that is required for your
pipeline now this is in a true sense the
DevOps approach where I'm gonna save
this out so if at all you have a
pipeline defined for your project the
best place to kind of put out your
configurations for the pipeline is
within your repository so this may be a
different project that I was referring
to but assuming that you have your
project where you know you have to
define your pipeline instead of putting
that as a particular job on Jenkins and
fearing that if Jenkins fails other jobs
there's a crash and then you lose out
your job configuration
the best approach is to use a jenkins
file put all the steps that is required
the tried tested steps that is required
as a part of your jenkins file and then
you can put out a job that can pull the
source code from here as well as use the
steps that is defined in a jet kins file
so let me end up by putting up and their
job which is a true jobs kind of a job
so I would say DevOps pipeline and this
is a pipeline script and then I'm not
going to say any of these things I would
say the pipeline script is from the
source code management so my pipeline
script is already defined it is present
in a same so what is my s V and I mean
what is my source code repository this
is my source code repository where I
already have this so let me copy this
URL this is my URL I don't need any
crunches because the repositories anyway
in public repository that is all that is
required I would say and the scripted
file it automatically picks up Jenkins
file alright so let me save this let me
pull this so that's the beauty of
swear in I have a pipeline that is
defined and instead of putting the
pipeline as a job because pipeline is
nothing but a configuration the
configuration is also checked into the
source code repository and any changes
to this pipeline instead of putting that
modifications in the job these are all
captured as a part of my repository so
the changes are nicely configured so
that you know we know who's done what
change we have almost reached the end of
this tutorial now Matthew will help you
learn some of the most important devups
and jenkins questions that you might
tackle in any divorce interview hello
this is matthew from simply learned and
today we're going to go through part one
of a two part series on interview
questions that you are likely to be
asked if you are interviewing for a job
that focuses on DevOps so let's just get
into those general DevOps questions so
one of the questions that you're going
to be asked is how is DevOps different
from agile and the reality is is that
DevOps is a cultural way of being able
to deliver solutions that's different
from agile we look at the evolution of
delivery over the last five to ten years
we've gone from waterfall and based
delivery to agile delivery which is on
Sprint's to where we are with continuous
integration and continuous delivery
around DevOps the whole concept of
DevOps is culturally very very different
from agile and the difference is is that
you're looking at being able to do
continuous releases what does that mean
the difference is is that you want to be
able to send out code continuously to
your production environment that means
the operations team the development team
have to be working together that means
that any code that gets created has to
be able to go to production very quickly
which means you need to be testing your
code continuously and then that
production environment must also be able
to be tested continuously and any
changes or any errors that come up have
to be communicated effectively and
efficiently back to the dev and opti
another area in which I see that DevOps
is different is really the response that
we have for how we engage with the
customer so the customer is coming to
your
website to your mobile app to your chat
bot or any digital solution that you
have and has an expectation when you're
going through and actually doing a dev
ops paradigm the old model would be that
you would capture requirements from the
customer then you do your development
then you do your testing and there would
be these barriers between each of those
as we move faster through from waterfall
to agile what we saw is that with agile
we were able to respond much faster to
customer demand so instead of being
weeks or months sometimes in some cases
years between releases of software what
we saw it would was a transition to
weeks and months for releases on
software now we see with DevOps is that
the release cycle has shrunk even
further with the goal of continuously
delighting the customer how further has
that release cycle shrunk to there are
companies that have gone from having
releases of once a week or once every
two weeks or once a month to now having
multiple releases a day indeed some
companies have up to 50 releases a day
this isn't something to also bear in
mind is that each of those releases are
tested and verified against test records
so that you can guarantee that the code
that's going to production is going to
be good continuous code so what are the
differences between the different phases
of DevOps so effectively there are two
main phases of DevOps there's the
planning and coding phase and then
there's the deploying phase and you have
a tool such as Jenkins that allows you
to integrate between both environments
some of the core benefits that you may
have to dev ARBs are going to be some
technical benefits and some business
benefit so if somebody asks you what are
the benefits of DevOps
you can reply that from a technical
point of view you're able to use
continuous software delivery to
constantly push out code that has been
tested and verified against scripts that
have been written and approved you can
be able to push out smaller chunks of
code so that when you have an issue
you're not having to go through massive
blocks of code or massive projects you
go through just probably small
microservices or small sections of code
and you're able to detect and correct
problems faster on the business side the
benefits are absolutely fantastic from a
customer that's coming to your website
and or to your mobile app they're gonna
see it responses happening continuously
so that the customer is always aware
that you as a company are listening to
their demands and responding
appropriately you're able to provide a
more stable environment and you're able
to scale that environment to the demands
of the number of customers that are
using your services so how do you
approach a project that needs to
implement dev ops so this is really an
exciting area for you to be in
so there are effectively three stages
when it comes to actually working in a
dev ops the first stage is an assessment
stage and think of this as the back of
the napkin ideation stage this is where
you are sitting with a business leader
and they're giving you ideas of what
they would like to see from feedback
that they've had from their customers
this is blue sky opportunity this is
thinking of big ideas that second stage
and this often comes as a fast follow to
stage one is actually proving out that
concept so developing a proof of concept
and a proof of concept can actually be
multiple different things so it could be
something as simple as a wireframe or it
could be something that is as complex as
a mini version of the final application
depending on the scope of the work that
you're delivering will really depend on
how complicated you want the POC to be
but with that in mind whatever choice
you make you have to be able to deliver
enough in the POC so that when you
present this to a customer they're able
to respond to that creation that you've
developed and able to give you feedback
to be able to validate that you are
going with the right solution and able
to provide the right product to your
customers that third stage is where you
get into your dev Ops stage and this is
just the exciting part this is where the
rubber hits the road and you start
releasing code but based on a back
of features that are being requested for
the solution in contrast to doing agile
delivery where you just continuously
work through a backlog with DevOps what
you're also looking at is putting in
analytics and sensors to be able to
validate that you are being successful
with the solution that's being delivered
so that once you've actually start
delivering out code that customers can
interact with you want to be able to see
what are the pieces of the solution that
they are using what do they like what is
complicated where are the failure points
and you want to use that data and feed
that back into your continuous
integration and have that as a means to
be able to backfill the demand of work
that gets completed in the bank flog so
what is the difference between
continuous delivery and continuous
deployment so continuous delivery is
based on putting out code that can be
deployed safely to production and
ensures that your businesses and
functions are running as you would
expect them to be so it's going through
and completing the code that you would
actually see continuous deployment in
contrast is all about ensuring that you
are automating the deployment of a
production environment so you're able to
go through and scale up your environment
to meet the demand of both the solution
and the customer this makes software
development and release processes much
more faster and more robust so if we
look here we can actually see where
continuous integration and continuous
deployment come hand-in-hand so when you
actually start out with the initial
pushes of your code that's where you're
doing your continuous integration and
your continuous delivery and then at
some point you want to get very
comfortable with deploying the code that
you're creating so it's being pushed out
to your production environments one of
the things that's great about working
with the tools that you use in a DevOps
continuous integration and continuous
delivery model is that the development
tools that you use the containerization
tools the testing tools should always
reflect the production environment and
what this means is that
when you actually come to deploying
solutions to production there are no
surprises because your development team
have been working against that exact
same environment all the way through so
a question that you'll also be asked is
you know what is the role of the
configuration management and dev ops and
so the role of configuration management
really has three distinct areas I'm the
first and this is really obvious one and
this is the one where you probably
already have significant experiences is
the ability manage and handle large
changes to multiple systems in seconds
rather than days hours or weeks as that
may have happened before the second area
is that you want to also demonstrate the
business reasons for having
configuration management and the
business reason here is that it allows
IT and infrastructure to standardize on
resource configurations and this has a
benefit in that you're able to do more
with fewer people so instead of having a
large configuration team you can
actually have a smaller more highly
skilled team that's able to actually
manage an even larger operational
environment and thirdly you want to be
able to highlight the ability to scale
so if you have configuration management
tools you're able to manage a
significant number of servers and
domains that may have multiple servers
and it allows you to effectively manage
servers that are deployed on cloud or
private cloud and allow you to do this
with high accuracy so how does
continuous monitoring help and maintain
the entire architecture of the system so
when this question comes up you want to
dig in and show your knowledge on how
configuration and continuous monitoring
is able to control an entire environment
so the number one topic that you want to
bring up when it comes to continuous
monitoring is that worth being able to
effectively monitor your entire network
24/7 for any changes as they happen
you're able to identify it report those
faults or threats immediately and
respond immediately
for your entire network instead of
having to wait as it happens sometimes
for a customer to email or call you and
say hey your website's down nobody wants
that that's an embarrassing thing the
other three areas that you want to be
able to highlight are the ability to be
able to ensure that the right software
and the right services are running on
the right resources that's your number
one takeaway that you want to be able to
give of continuous monitoring the second
is to be able to monitor the status of
those servers continuously this is not
requiring manually monitoring but having
a agent that's monitoring those servers
continuously and then the third is that
by scripting out and continuously
monitoring your entire environment
you're creating a self audit trail that
you can take back and demonstrate the
effectiveness of the operations
environment that you are providing so
one of the cloud companies that is a
strong advocate for DevOps is Amazon's
Web Services AWS and they have a really
five distinct areas that you can zero in
on board services so when the question
comes up what is the role of AWS in
DevOps and you want to really hold out
your hand and list of five areas of
focus using your thumb and finger so you
want to have flexible services built for
scale automation secure and a large
partner ecosystem and having those five
areas will really be able to help
demonstrate why you believe that AWS and
and other cloud providers but AWS are 70
the leader in this space are great for
being able to provide support for the
role of DevOps so one of the things that
we want to be able to do effectively
when we're releasing any kind of
solution is to be able to measure that
solution and so KPIs are very important
so you will be asked for three important
dev of KPIs and so three that really
come to mind that are very effective the
first one is mean time to failure
recovery and what this talks about is
what is the average time does it take to
recover from a failure and if you have
experience doing this then look at the
experience you have and use a specific
example
where you were able to demonstrate that
mean time to failure recovery
the second is deployment frequency and
with deployment frequency you want to be
able to discuss how often do you
actually deploy solutions and what
actually happens when you actually doing
those deployments and what does the
impacts to your network look like when
you're doing those deployments and then
the third one is really tied to that
deployment frequency which is around
what is the percentage of failed
deployments and so how many times did
you deploy to a server and something
happened where the server itself failed
what we're looking for when you're going
through and being asked for these KPIs
is experience with actually doing a
DevOps deployment and being able to
understand what DevOps looks like when
you're pushing out your infrastructure
and then the second is being able to
validate that self auditing ability and
one word of caution is don't go in there
and say that you have a hundred percent
success the reality is that servers do
degrade over time and you maybe want to
talk about a time when a server did
degrade in your environment and use that
as a story for how you were able to
successfully get over and solve that
degradation so one of the terms that is
very popular at the moment is
infrastructure as code and so you're
going to be asked to explain
infrastructure as code and really it's
it's something that actually becomes a
byproduct of the work you have to do
when you're actually putting together
your DevOps environment and
infrastructure as code really refers to
the writing of code to actually manage
your environment and you can go through
many of the other tools that we've
covered in this series but you'll see
that XML or Ruby or Yama are used as
languages to describe the configuration
for your environment this allows you to
then create the rules and instructions
that can be read by the machines that
are actually setting up the physical
Hardware versus a traditional model
which is having software and installing
a software directly onto the machine
this is really important when it comes
to cloud computing there really is a
strong emphasis of being able to explain
infrastructure as a service and
as code is fundamental to the foundation
to infrastructure as service and then
finally allows you to be able to talk
about how you can use scripted languages
such as Yammer to be able to create a
consistent experience for your entire
network all right let's talk about the
next section which is continuous
integration with Jenkins so the first
question you'll be asked about with
Jenkins is explained a master/slave
architecture of Jenkins so the way that
Jenkins is set up is that the Jenkins
master will pull code from your remote
git repository such as github and we'll
check that repository every time there
is a code commit it will distribute the
workload of that code and the tests that
need to be applied to code to all of the
Jenkins slaves and then on request the
jenkum Marsan the slaves will then carry
out all the builds and tests to be able
to produce test reports the next
question you'll be asked is what is a
Jenkins file and simply put a Jenkins
file as a text file that has a
definition of the Jenkins pipeline and
is checked into a source code repository
and this really allows for three
distinct things to happen one it allows
for a code review and iteration of the
pipeline it permits an audit trail for
that pipeline and also provides a single
source of truth for the pipeline which
can be viewed and edited so which of the
following commands runs Jenkins from the
command line is it Java - John Jenkins
dope war Java - war Jenkins dot jar Java
dot - JA Jenkins jar Java - war Jenkins
dot wall and the answer is a Java dash
jar
Jenkins dot war so when working with
Jenkins you're gonna be asked what are
the key concepts and aspects of working
with a Jenkins pipeline and you want to
really hold out your fingers here and go
through four key areas and that is
pipeline node step and stay so pipeline
refers to the user-defined model of a CD
continues till every pipeline node are
the machines which is which are part
that Jenkins environment within the
pipeline step is a single task that
tells Jenkins what to do at that
particular point in time and then
finally stage defines a conceptually
distinct subset of tasks performed
through the entire pipeline and tasks
could be build test and deploy so which
of the following file is used to define
dependency in mavin and do we have a
build XML B palm dat XML C dependency
XML or D version dot XML and the answer
is palm XML working with Jenkins you're
going to be asked to explain the two
types of pipeline used in Jenkins along
with the syntax and so a scripted
pipeline is based on groovy script as a
domain-specific language for Jenkins
there are one or more node blocks that
are used throughout the entire pipeline
on the left hand side you can see see
what the actual script would look like
and the right hand side shows what the
actual declaration for each section of
that script would be the second type of
Jenkins pipeline is a declarative
pipeline and a declarative pipeline
writes a simple and a friendly syntax to
define what the pipeline should look
like and then you can actually at this
point use an example to actually break
out how blocks are used to find the work
completed in a decorative pipeline so
how do you create a copy and backup of
Jenkins well to create a backup Prarie
African backup Jenkins your Jenkins home
directory and then create a copy of that
directory it's really as simple as that
the question you'll be asked as well is
how can you copy Jenkins from one server
to another well they're essentially
there are three ways to do that one is
you can move a job from one installation
of Jenkins to another by copying the
corresponding job directory the second
would be to create a copy of an existing
job directory and making a clone of that
job directory but with a different name
and the third is to rename an existing
job by renaming a directory so security
is fundamental to all the work that we
do within DevOps
Jenkins provides the center core to all
the work that gets completed within a
DevOps environment there are three ways
in which you can apply security to
authenticate users effectively and when
you are asked about this question of
security within Jenkins the three
responses you want to be able to provide
is a Jenkins has its own internal
database that uses secured user data
from end user credentials be is you can
use a LDAP or lightweight directory
access protocol server to be able to
authenticate Jenkins users or see you
can actually configure Jenkins to
authenticate by using such as Oh earth
which is a more modern method of being
able to authenticate users you're going
to be asked how to deploy a custom build
of a core plug-in within Jenkins and
essentially the four steps you want to
go through first of all copying the HPI
plug-in file into the Jenkins home
plugins subdirectory you want to remove
the plugins development directory if
there is one you want to create an empty
file called plug-in HPI dot pinned and
once you've completed these three steps
restart Jenkins and your custom build
plug-in should be available how can you
temporarily turn off Jenkins security if
the administrative user has locked
themselves out of the admin console this
doesn't happen very often but when it
does it's good to know how you can
actually get into Jenkins and be able to
resolve the problems of authenticating
effectively into the system as an
administrator so when you want to be
able to get into a Jenkins environment
what you want to be able to do is locate
the config file you should see that it's
set to true which allows for security to
be enabled if you then change the user
security setting to false security will
disabled allow you to make your
administrative changes and will not be
re-enabled until the next time
Jenkins is restarted so what are the
ways in which a build can be scheduled
and run in Jenkins well there are four
ways in which you can I
by the way a build can be scheduled on
Ryan Jenkins the first is when source
code management commits new code into
the repository you can run Jenkins at
that point the second can be the carafe
to the completion of other bills so
maybe you have multiple builds in your
project that are dependent to each other
and when so many other builds have been
executed then you can have Jenkins run
you can schedule bill to run at a
specified time so you may have nightly
builds of your code that illustrate the
changes in the solution you're building
and then finally you also can manually
build a environment on request
occasionally you will want to also
restart Jenkins and so it's good that
when a question around how do you
restart Jenkins manually comes up that
you have the answers and there are two
ways in which you can do it one is you
can force a restart without waiting for
bills complete by using the Jenkins URL
that you have for your environment slash
restart or you can allow all running
builds to complete before restart are
required in which case you would use the
command of the URL field Jenkins
environments that safe Rhys Darby I hope
this helps you in your interview with
that we have reached the end of this
complete Jenkins tutorial I hope you
enjoyed this video do like and share it
thank you for watching and stay tuned
for more from simply learn
[Music]